Just just just just just bait it, just just just just bait it.
So Leute, das immer wieder.
Und wie man sieht, ist mal eine Demo ausgelaufen.
Ne, nicht wirklich nice, das zackt.
Demo Versionen die auslaufen zacken richtig.
So, ich muss jetzt erstmal warten bis Twitch kapiert hat, dass der Stream online ist.
Das dauert ja immer so 5 Minuten oder so.
Selbst mein Browser kann sich nicht entscheiden, ob der Stream jetzt online ist oder nicht.
Ist auch geil.
Omega Lull.
Mein Browser Twitch die ganze Zeit bei dem Stream zwischen ist online oder ist es nicht online?
Ich hab auch keine Zuschaueranzeige oder irgendwas.
Aber ich seh die Vorschau.
Twitch hat sich doch nicht überlegt, ob der Stream jetzt online oder offline ist.
Oh, Mister Ami ist am Start.
Hast du Twitch Benachrichtigung gekriegt oder hast du es einfach so gesehen, dass der Stream online ist?
Twitch hat auch keine Benachrichtigung verschickt.
Wenn Twitch Benachrichtigung verschickt hätte, da wärs nicht nur ein Zuschauer.
Bisschen laut, ne?
Wupp wupp wupp.
Oh, besser.
Ganz so laut.
So, ich offere das Twitch.
Ah, jetzt ist der Stream online. Jetzt hat Twitch gecheckt.
Nice.
Und jetzt sind die Leute am Start, ja.
Ich seh das nämlich immer.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig auf Twitch.
Wenn man den Stream anmacht, dann dauert es so 5 Minuten oder so, bis Twitch die Nachrichten rausschickt, glaube ich.
Weil ich sitze meistens die ersten 5 Minuten immer mit einem Zuschauer da.
Und ein Zuschauer ist halt mein Vorschau, mein Vorschaubild.
Und auf einen Schlag kommen dann immer irgendwie so ungefähr nach 5 Minuten, kommen dann auf einen Schlag immer irgendwie 20 Leute und dann gehts halt rauf.
Die Mannlager ausmachen, das ist eigentlich ein bisschen zu kühl dafür.
First World Problems, ich weiß, Leute.
So, kann man das jetzt starten?
Disable. Disable. Alles, alles disablen.
Aber alles nicht.
Wow.
Monka Java.
Java S.
Ist das jetzt, startet das jetzt oder startet das jetzt nicht?
Man weiß es nicht.
Ah, ah, ok. Jetzt gehts, ja.
Ok, was auch immer. Java Logik.
Perfekt. Ich brauch das ja eh nur, um das Programm zu starten, dass ich meinen Chat mit, meinen Chatlog hab.
Jetzt mach ich auch, ja, ja.
8-90% CPU, weil es geht.
Come on, brah, starten.
Ich glaub, jetzt hat er es geschafft.
Man sieht hier, wie das alles reinleckt auch schon.
So, jetzt. Darf ich jetzt?
Ah, ich glaub, jetzt darf ich starten. Ok, sehr schön.
Ja, Leute, also.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es gesehen habt.
Aber falls nicht, zeige ich euch das jetzt noch mal.
Und zwar, es gibt jetzt, ähm, morgen gesehen, für die Switch gibt es einen Android.
Seit gestern, offiziell.
Also offiziell, offiziell soll ich, nein, nicht offiziell, also nicht von Nintendo oder so.
Aber es gibt jetzt einen Release von den Dudes.
Halt, erst offizielles Release von denen, nicht von Nintendo.
Von Nintendo, das glaubt ihr ja im Leben nicht.
Frage. Kennst du welche Router, die Warnbonding können?
Ähm, das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, ähm, in welchem Umfeld.
Weil, also willst du einfach nur Interfaces bonden?
Das kann jeder bisschen bessere Router oder jeder bisschen besserer Switch.
Oder willst du wirklich zwei verschiedene, nennen wir es mal ab links, zu ähm, unterschiedlichen Providern bonden?
Das könnte ja dann auch sein, dass quasi vor dem einen ein Kabelmodem ist und vor dem anderen ein DSL-Modem.
Oder dazwischen.
Äh, wenn du sowas willst, dann brauchst du, also entweder Loadbalancest du das.
Das ist dann, je nach Anwendung, bringt das was oder bringt nichts.
Ähm, also das kannst du ohne Gegenstelle machen.
Du kannst das, du kannst das Loadbalancen.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich so jeder 0815 Router können, der keine Fritzbox ist.
Kannst auch irgendein MikroTik Ding nehmen oder sowas.
Da kannst du einfach quasi versuchen zu Loadbalancen zwischen den Anschlüssen.
Du kannst wahrscheinlich sogar einstellen, wenn der eine schneller ist als der andere, 80% darüber, 20% darüber.
Das sorgt nicht dafür, dass du jetzt bei einem einzelnen Download, es sei denn du machst mehrere Sessions, aber so pauschal erstmal nicht,
dass du bei einem Download jetzt, ähm, anstatt, keine Ahnung, 100 MBit, 200 MBit hast.
Das ist gut dafür, wenn du mehrere Benutzer dahinter hast mit unterschiedlichen Verbindungen.
Dann funktioniert eigentlich Loadbalancen über zwei Internetleitungen ganz gut.
Für einen einzelnen Download eher nicht so und also für einen einzelnen User eher nicht so gut.
Wenn du wirklich das, ähm, sagen wir mal so bonden willst, dass das eine einzelne Verbindung benutzen kann,
dann brauchst du auf der Gegenseite irgendeinen Tunnelendpunkt oder irgendein Endpunkt, der das auch kann.
Also dann nimmst du entweder einen, wie heißt der Kram?
Muss ich mir mal gelanken zu machen, wie der Kram hieß.
Das macht man so selten oder zumindest so selten, wenn man nicht irgendwie bei einem Provider arbeitet oder so.
Dann brauchst du so einen Multi-Point-Dings-Endpunkt und das kann beispielsweise ein selbstgemieteter Linux-Server sein,
bei Hetzner oder irgendwo anders oder irgendeine selbstgemietete VM, die die entsprechende Bandbreite hat.
Und dann musst du von einem Router zu deiner Kiste im Internet brauchst du dann quasi einen,
brauchst du mehr oder weniger so einen Layer-2-Bonding drüber von einem Router über die Internetanschlüsse zu deinem Server.
Das heißt, dein Ausgang ist auch der Server, den du gemietet hast.
Das ist aber relativ kompliziert.
Also so einfach, ich habe zwei Internetanschlüsse und möchte die bonden, geht gar nicht.
Also entweder brauchst du eine Gegenstelle, die das kann, musst du halt selbst installieren oder irgendwas Fertiges holen,
oder aber du Loadbalancen einfach zwischen den beiden Internetanschlüssen.
Das bringt dir dann aber für eine einzelne Verbindung nichts.
Das ist halt wiederum relativ einfach.
Wenn du jetzt sagen wir mal, wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine, keine Ahnung, 2, 3, 4, 5-köpfige Familie seid,
dann ist das Loadbalancen zwischen Internetanschlüssen gar nicht verkehrt,
weil dann kann es, was weiß ich, dann können die Kinder aus Netflix streamen über Telekom-Anschluss
und du kannst irgendwie Steam downloaden über Unity Media, also das funktioniert.
Dafür ist ein Loadbalancen zwischen zwei Internetanschlüssen okay, aber halt nicht für eine einzelne Verbindung.
Habt ihr das verstanden?
Ansonsten wird es echt komplizierter.
Wenn du die wirklich zusammen für eine Verbindung verwenden willst.
Das ist nicht so, das ist nicht so einfach.
Also das ist nicht so einfach gemacht, wenn man macht ein Häkchen rein,
da brauchst du auf jeden Fall eine Gegenstelle, die das auch kann.
Ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt, Multi, Multi-Point.
Ich weiß es nicht, müsste ich genauer nachhören, wie der ganze Kampel heißt.
Ja, moin Leute, also für alle, die jetzt gerade eingeschaltet haben,
ich hab heute Morgen gesehen, es gibt jetzt für die Switch,
muss ich über den Browser mal überlegen, wie das aussehen soll.
Sollte das nicht vielleicht so ein bisschen galieren oder so?
Na ja, egal.
Ich hab heute Morgen gesehen, es gibt jetzt für die Switch, gibt's in Android,
halt natürlich kein offizielles von Nintendo,
allerdings haben jetzt wohl eins, die Typen, die da dran arbeiten,
jetzt wohl eins released.
Das Ganze basiert auf Lineage OS 15.1, wo anscheinend Orion drunter ist.
Und es ist relativ naheliegend, dass es das ist, weil
in der Switch ist ja mehr oder weniger das, was in den Nvidia Shield Dingern drinne ist.
Das heißt, es sollte von der Architektur relativ einfach sein,
rein zum Laufen zu bringen, das Shield Android.
Das Problem ist bloß, dass halt die Switch im Endeffekt nichts davon hat, was ein Tablet hat.
Also du hast keine Kameras richtig, wobei ich weiß gar nicht,
hat die Switch eine Kamera?
Eine steht im Wohnzimmer, ich kann nicht gucken.
Hat die Switch eigentlich eine Kamera?
Zumindest hat die Switch definitiv kein Mikrofon und sowas.
Es sei denn, wenn man irgendwie diese komische App verwendet.
So, wir gucken uns das mal an.
Wir gucken uns mal an, was man so machen kann mit dem Android für die Switch.
Ist die leise, oder?
Ist die leise, können wir sie lauter machen, ne?
Das ist gut.
Habt ihr es gehört, der hat es richtig gesagt, ne?
Ich sage ja Ubuntu immer nicht wie die coolen Leute, aber der sagt es richtig.
Pass auf, Ubuntu hat er gesagt, das ist eine Kombination aus Ubuntu oder Ubuntu, das ist Ubuntu.
Ubuntu, Ubuntu, Ubuntu, Leute.
Ubuntu hat er gesagt, das ist eine Kombination aus Ubuntu oder Ubuntu, das ist Ubuntu.
Ubuntu, das ist Ubuntu.
Kann man die Switch eigentlich, naja, ich würde mal sagen,
Android auf der Switch laufen zu lassen, ist schon ziemlich nicht von Nintendo gedacht.
Flame Haze, also ich würde schon mal sagen, ja.
Moment, EMU MMC, ist das nicht, ist das nicht der Switch Emulator?
Heißt das, ich kann jetzt, oh das ist ja Vollmeter,
ich kann jetzt unter der Switch Linux laufen, was einen Switch Emulator laufen lässt?
Das ist ja, das ist ja, da weiß ich, das ist total abgedreht.
Switch mit Linux mit einem Switch Emulator drauf, easy, easy, 5 FPS.
Hast du beruflich eigentlich auch mit externen Personen zu tun oder nur mit internen?
Bist du mal mit allen Zuschauern, ja, Zuschauern bin ich begegnet.
Und auf der Arbeit, das sind Sauermann, 95% sind interne Leute.
Aber ich bin auch niemand, der sich dafür eignet, großartig mit Außendienst
oder irgendwelchen anderen Leuten da Kontakt zu haben.
Die gehen ja prinzipiell eh alle Leute auf den Sack.
Und wenn man im Außendienst ist bzw. mit Leuten zu tun hat,
dann muss man da halt auch ein bisschen schleimen und das kriege ich nicht hin.
Oder wenigstens ein bisschen nett sein, weil man merkt, die Leute sind nervig.
Ja, also da bin ich auch der Falsche für funktioniert nämlich.
Am besten war mal, wo ich wieder gesehen habe,
dass ich niemals Hotline oder so einen Blödsinn machen will, ist,
hat mal irgendeiner von einem anderen Standort eine Mail geschrieben an unser Postfach.
Und die, oh fuck, ich habe fast wieder meinen Tee verschüttet, ja.
Und die wollte offensichtlich nicht zu uns.
Die hat irgendwas gefragt, so nach dem Motto, warum geht das System nicht?
Also die übliche Frage, die man an der Hotline immer kriegt.
Also warum geht das System nicht?
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, die ist jetzt zwar bei uns rausgekommen,
aber ich weiß, dass die definitiv nicht zu uns will.
Also habe ich mir gedacht, ey komm bist du mal nett, das war schon der erste Fehler.
Und habe mir zurückgeschrieben, ich weiß gar nicht, um welches System es geht.
Und ich denke, sie ist bei uns falsch, sie soll bei der Hotline anrufen.
Aber anstatt, dass sie bei der Hotline angerufen hätte,
hat sie mir zurückgeschrieben, von welchem System sie spricht.
Und zwar hat sie geschrieben, es geht um das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten.
Bitte schnellstens Fehler beheben.
So, dann habe ich mir nur das hier gedacht.
Warum alles in der Welt soll ich wissen, mit welchem System sie täglich arbeitet?
Ich weiß nur, dass wir garantiert nicht für dieses System da sind.
Das ist so, deswegen, ich will definitiv nicht bei der Hotline, nie, nie will ich bei der Hotline arbeiten.
Ich meine, auf die Frage hin, welches System zu antworten, das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten,
das ist echt schon ziemlich bescheuert.
Ich meine, die wusste das nicht besser, aber es ist trotzdem irgendwie beknackt.
Naja, und übrigens letztens habe ich auch wieder die volle...
Ich mal gucken, ob ich auf Twitter gepostet habe.
Die volle BWL-Logik mitbekommen.
Ach so, übrigens, meine China-USB-Kabel sind da.
Wer es nicht auf Twitter gesehen hat.
Das sind 50 USB-Kabel.
Mikro-USB auf USB-C.
Also normal auf Mikro-USB und da ist ein Stecker,
dabei mit USB-C, das heißt, man hat alles abgefackelt, was man so braucht.
Warum so viele?
Weil ich bei AliExpress nur 46 Euro gekostet habe, inklusive Versand.
Also das heißt, wir haben 50...
Also für 92 Cent pro USB.
Bitte um Link.
Ich habe es versucht, auf Twitter zu posten.
Hat nämlich schon jemand gefragt.
Allerdings gibt es das Angebot nicht mehr.
Du musst mal bei AliExpress suchen.
Sogar einfach bei AliExpress 2 in 1 in einem Wort geschrieben.
Und dann gibt es das Angebot nicht mehr.
2 in 1 USB.
Und da musst du dich mal ein bisschen durchscrollen.
Du kannst dir irgendwie noch so viel dabei eingeben, oder 50 oder irgendwas.
Und dann irgendwann, wenn du dich hier mal durchscrollst,
Ah, hier geht's schon in die richtige Richtung.
Und dann musst du dir einfach nur günstiges raussuchen.
Das sind bestimmt auch ein paar.
Das sind 500 Stück, guck mal.
Also, das ist wirklich bei AliExpress echt günstig.
Aber 92 Cent pro USB-Kabel ist sehr nice.
Wenn man sich überlegt, da ist ja Versand schon dabei gewesen.
DHL-Versand wohl gemerkt.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, ob die überhaupt an dem USB-Kabel was verdient haben.
Also, ich hab mal ein paar Kabels ausprobiert.
Die funktionieren eigentlich ganz gut.
Und es stimmt ja gar nicht, dass China nur Schrott verkauft.
Du hast die Chance, wenn du halt billig krammst bei AliExpress,
dass das Schrott ist, ist halt relativ hoch.
Aber es gibt auch mittlerweile gute China-Sachen.
Beispielsweise einen Staubsauger-Ropper.
Das ist echt gut, das Teil.
Verkaufst du die? Nein, ich behalte die.
Weil ich hab mir die ja bestellt,
dass ich quasi für die nächsten Jahre genug USB-Kabel hab.
Deswegen hab ich auch explizit welche gesucht,
die USB auf Mikro-USB sind und USB-C.
Weil das ist das, was du für die nächsten Jahre brauchst.
Aktuell hast du zum größten Teil noch Mikro-USB.
Und in Zukunft hast du immer mehr USB-C.
So, und das hast du jetzt in Kombination.
Jetzt hast du USB auf Mikro-USB oder alternativ auf USB-C.
Also besser, besser kann es eigentlich gar nicht funktionieren.
Die Musik bisschen laut.
Ah ja, weil ich zu laut gemacht hab.
Ja.
Genau, wollte ich euch jetzt eigentlich gar nicht zeigen.
Die Kabel sind da, ich wundere nicht,
die sind angekommen, die funktionieren.
Und ich finde, es sieht auf einem Haufen viel mehr aus,
als ich gedacht hab.
So, und letztens hab ich wieder die, hier, das da.
So geil, hab ich Aussage auf der Arbeit, ne?
Ist auch geil.
Hat irgendjemand erzählt, ich glaub, das war aus dem Datenbankumfeld,
hat jemand erzählt, also unsere SLA sagen maximal 30 Minuten Datenverlust.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, ja, okay, was machen wir, wenn es länger dauert?
Und dann kam die absolute Big Brain Aussage schlechthin,
wir schalten einfach das System ab, damit wir keine Daten mehr bekommen.
Das ist Massive Brain, ey.
Man hat quasi zugesagt, man hat maximal 30 Minuten Datenverlust
und wenn es länger dauert, nimmt man einfach keine neuen Daten mehr an,
dass man nicht mehr als 30 Minuten Datenverlust hat.
Das ist huge, das ist wirklich ganz, ganz groß, Big Brain, ey.
Das ist wieder so die typische, typische BWL-Logik, ey.
Was sind SLAs?
Das ist quasi ein Vertrag, den du hast mit irgendjemand,
wo drin steht, wie verfügbar was ist.
Service Level Agreement heißt das.
Wobei ich mir bei euch immer nicht sicher bin, bei meinem Chat,
weil ich weiß ja, dass ich Big Brain Chat hab,
ob die Leute es wirklich fragen oder ob die so fragen nach dem Motto,
Who Cares SLAs?
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, also Android, Android auf der Switch.
Ubuntu.
Moment, wollen wir erstmal Sound aus.
Okay.
Emo MMC ist doch echt jetzt noch der Switch Emulator, oder?
Ich find das so geil, dass man dann auf der Switch die Switch emulieren kann.
Das ist ja geil.
Ich hab einen Fleck auf dem Bildschirm, seh ich, gerade wenn der Hintergrund so weiß ist.
Seht ihr den auch?
Das hat mal Dings hier, hat mal BibisBeautyPalace auf Twitter gepostet.
So nach dem Motto, oh mein Gott, ich hab einen Bildschirmfehler
und hab einen Screenshot von gemacht.
Das war auch Massive Brain, ey.
Wobei ich mir aber bei der gar nicht so sicher bin, ob die blöd ist oder nicht.
Aber ich bin mir sicher, dass sie blöd ist.
Wobei ich mir aber bei der gar nicht so sicher bin, ob die blöd ist in der Richtung
oder ob das einfach der übelste Gebate ist, dass die Leute reacten auf Twitter.
Da hab ich ja drauf gewartet, Linux zu starten auf der Switch,
damit ich dann Minecraft auf der Switch, also dass ich dann unter Linux Minecraft auf der Switch spielen kann.
Gibt's Minecraft nicht eh schon für die Switch mittlerweile?
Es gibt doch mittlerweile fast alles alte für die Switch.
Es gibt sogar Doom für die Switch.
Ich hab am Morgen auch in den News gelesen, es gibt jetzt Doom 1, 2, 3 für die Switch.
Allerdings hat sich Bethesda gedacht, wir können da ja kein 30 Jahre altes Game
auf der Switch ohne DRM releasen.
Und jetzt haben sie in Doom 1 hat Bethesda DRM eingebaut für die Switch.
Da können wir uns auch gleich noch ein Video zu angucken.
Das stimmt.
Ich bin geneigt dazu, das mal mit meiner Switch auszuprobieren,
weil ich verwende meine Switch eh so gut wie nicht.
Und ich hab ne Release-Switch, die ist mit Sicherheit alt genug, dass das funktioniert.
Das ist nice.
Das heißt, ich kann Linux installieren auf der Switch, da kann ich Portal 2 in Linux spielen.
Das Tegra-Ding ist für das, wenn man sich überlegt, wie alt diese Tegra-Plattform ist,
ist das ziemlich schnell.
Ja ok, das kann ich verstehen.
Du darfst ja Netflix in eurer Auflösung nur gucken, wenn du HDCP und sowas kannst.
Also wenn dein HDMI-HDCP und dein Fernseh-HDCP und alles HDCP kann zwischendurch.
Das Touch auf der Switch sagt übelst.
Wozu?
Das beste daran dürfte sein, dass man endlich nen ordentlichen Browser auf der Switch hat.
Dafür lohnt sich das, weil Nintendo hat's eh immer noch nicht geschafft.
Oder? Ich hab schon ewig die Switch nehmen angehabt.
Letztes Mal, wo ich News geguckt hab, gab's immer noch keinen Browser.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Dazu brauchst du nicht unbedingt eine Switch.
Aber das Coole an der Switch ist, dass ein Controller mit dabei ist.
Ich würd das sogar mal ausprobieren hier.
Ich würd das sogar eigentlich mal Onstream ausprobieren.
Die Sache ist die, ich hab keine Ahnung ob man sowas Onstream ausprobieren darf.
Weil...
Ne?
Monka Toss.
Ich hätte schon Bedenken das Forum hier überhaupt aufzumachen und streamen.
Das ist bestimmt Monka Toss, das mach ich nicht.
Genau, wir gucken jetzt nochmal das Video.
Doom DRM Switch, das ist richtig, das ist massiv hängen geblieben.
Das ist richtig bescheuert, muss man sich jetzt mal überlegen.
Als hab ich heute Morgen schon zur Hälfte angeguckt, richtig hängen geblieben.
Das Doom Release auf der Switch.
Der muss mal gucken, dass sein Auto immer gleich laut ist.
Das ist doch Fail.
Das ist ein Game aus einer Zeit, da hatte noch nie jemand einen Internetanschluss daheim.
Okay, ganz wenige, ganz wenige hatten einen.
Die haben wirklich ein Game genommen von, genau 93 steht hier oben.
Und haben Onlinezwang eingebaut, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das ist richtig Fail.
Das ist so Fail.
Ich mein, du kannst das Game auf dem Drucker spielen mittlerweile.
Aber um es auf der Switch zu spielen, brauchst du einen Bethesda Onlinezwang Account.
Das ist richtig hängen geblieben.
Doom läuft auf meinem Drucker.
Ist jetzt kein Witz, Doom läuft wirklich auf meinem Drucker.
Was, Moment, die haben nicht das Original Game genommen, die haben Doom in Unity nachgebaut, sehe ich das richtig?
Hab ich das gerade richtig verstanden?
Das ist ja noch nicht mal Doom, das ist ja quasi ein offizieller Doom-Klon.
Und hier ist ein Bethesda-Port.
Das hört sich übelst kaputt an.
Das hört sich an als kackt die Switch gleich ab.
Hab ich das auch in Unity nachgebaut?
Das stellt mich ein bisschen aufwendig vor.
Doom 3 ist echt großartig.
Ich bin persönlich gar kein großartiger Fan von Doom 3, ich fand die ersten 1-2 Stunden echt nice.
Aber es ist halt überall dunkel und hinter jeder Tür ist irgendwas und mit der Zeit war Doom 3 nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Ich weiß, du läufst, das läuft auf alle.
Kannst du nochmal den Tanz mit dem Pippen zeigen? Kann ich sagen, ja, aber das passt jetzt nicht so, weil das kann ich nicht.
Aber das passt jetzt nicht so, weil das kann ich nicht.
Ok, jetzt kriegen wir gezeigt, wie man Schuhe bindet.
Ja, warum nicht?
Das ist ok.
Ja, wenn einem die 3 Sekunden, die das normal dauert, zu langsam sind und man so den krassen
Hexorschubinder machen will, dann ist das ja schon, vielleicht ist der Tipp wenigstens
mal ganz ok.
So, was kommt als nächstes?
Das ist nur für Leute mit großem Gehirn.
Ach, jetzt check ich das.
Du malst jede Zahl auf und dann zählst du die Punkte quasi, wo sie sich überschneiden.
Wobei ich glaube nicht, dass das japanisch ist.
So was fast alles, was irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise geometrisch aussieht, ist griechisch.
Die Griechen waren da echt erfinderisch, was das angeht.
Geht das nur von 0 bis 3, von 1 bis 3 oder geht das auch mit mehr?
Von der Idee her würde ich sagen, geht das auch mit mehr.
Das Problem dürfte nur sein, wenn man das mit größeren Zahlen macht, also mit höheren
einzelnen Zahlen, dass man dann viel, viel mehr Striche braucht und irgendwie das überhaupt
keinen Sinn mehr ergibt.
Ok, machen sie es nämlich auch wieder nur mit 1, 2, 3, 3, 2, 1.
Man lernt das in japanischen Schulen noch, ok.
Aber ich sag mal, easy Taschenrechner, easy life, kann ja auch Kalk auf dem Calculator
auf dem Handy sein.
Ich mein, das ist schon recht elegant.
Oder einfach Kopfrechnen, genau.
Die machen das aber immer nur mit 1, 2 und 3 oder?
Aber wahrscheinlich wird das einfach zu groß, wenn man das mit mehr Zahlen macht, mit größeren.
Wieder nur, wieder nur.
1, immer nur 0 bis 3.
Oder alternativ wisst ihr, was ihr auch machen könnt, wenn, ähm, wollte ich gerade sagen,
choose by name, wenn ihr, wenn ihr irgendwie so große Dinge, die eh keiner nachrechnen
kann, die eh keiner nachrechnen kann, dass ihr dann sagt, so ungefähr die erste Zahl,
die ist irgendwas mit 4 wahrscheinlich, so, weil, ne, das war 3, 3, so, irgendwas mit
4 oder sowas vorne vielleicht, dass man dann irgendwie sagt, keine Ahnung, 45.392.
Und 90% der Leute glauben mir das dann.
Wobei ist das, ne, das reicht überhaupt nicht für eine 4 vorne, ne.
Dann sagst du dann irgendwie 38.427.
Und dann sagen alle, boah, boah, boah, hast du aber schnell den Kopf gerechnet.
Was kommt raus?
Okay, was mit einer 3?
Ah, okay, 39.483.
Aber das kann eh keiner so schnell nachrechnen.
Okay, das ist ja langweilig.
Also außer den Schuhe-Bin-Trick fand ich davon jetzt nix irgendwie sonderlich toll.
Langweilig.
Wirst du eigentlich mal Google starten?
Ach so, wir können mal das Pepega-Board gucken.
Weißt du, ob man die Auto-Übersetzung von YouTube-Titel irgendwie verhindern kann?
Ja, ich glaub du kannst Google auf Englisch umstellen.
Das geht hier unten irgendwie, ne, fuck, wo ging das?
Man konnte Google auf Englisch umstellen.
WTF, wie krieg ich denn da empfohlen?
Früher war das unten auf der Seite, da konnte man die Sprache auswählen.
Das geht aber nimmer, weil Endless-Scroll.
Ach hier, Sprache.
Da kannst du die Sprache auf Englisch stellen und dann sollte das aufhören zu übersetzen.
Ink-Cartridges are scam.
Solange sie funktionieren sind sie kein Scam.
Sie sind auf jeden Fall zu teuer, die Original-Cartridges.
Dazwischen kaufe ich auch nur noch Trittanbieter-Drucker-Padronen.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch?
Wirst du Google Stadia ausprobieren?
Ich guck's mir vielleicht mal an, aber ich weiß jetzt schon, dass das für mich nix ist.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es wieder so ein typisches Google-Ding wird,
mit Riesentammtamm angekündigt und dann ein halbes Jahr später eingestellt, weil es sacken wird.
Ich kann nicht vergessen, die können ja alle nicht zaubern.
Also sei es, das ist ja auch nix Neues.
Das erste, was ich damals ausprobiert habe, war On-Live, hieß das, glaube ich.
Das war 2015 oder 2014 und sind schon ewig her.
Und die haben das im Prinzip auch so probiert.
Du hast quasi dort den Server stehen mit Grafikkarten drin, da ist dein Game drauf gelaufen und es hat zu dir gestreamt.
Mittlerweile ist natürlich die Internetanbindung bei den Leuten daheim besser
und Google hat natürlich auch mehr Infrastruktur deutschlandweit stehen als vielleicht so ein einzelner Anbieter.
Allerdings kann auch Google nicht zaubern.
Also auch bei Google ist die Lichtgeschwindigkeit Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Und auch bei Google braucht es eine gewisse Weile, bis was in den Rechner reinkommt und wieder rauskommt.
Es dauert auch eine gewisse Weile, bis von eurem Controller was dahin übertragen wird.
Also die können alle nicht zaubern.
Und dementsprechend denke ich, dass diese ganze Remote-Gaming-Geschichte einzig und allein für den Casual-Spieler relevant ist.
Natürlich sind das die meisten.
Allerdings sogar die, die Casual-mäßig, sagen wir mal, Battlefield spielen oder sowas,
sogar die werden das schon nicht über einen Streaming-Service machen.
Es werden so Leute sein, die einmal im Jahr das neue Assassin's Creed spielen oder so.
Die spielen das dann halt über Google Stadia vom Tablet mit Bluetooth-Controller oder sowas.
Allerdings Leute, die einen gewissen Anspruch haben an Responsiveness und spätestens mal Multiplayer spielen,
hört auch der Casual auf, sowas über Streaming-Anbieter zu spielen.
Wo gibt es deine Pepega-Board Soundfiles? Das Pepega-Board ist mein Chat-Programm. Was du meinst, ist das Meme-Board.
Das hört sich so doof an.
Äh, die gibt es gar nicht. Das ist einmal die in Windows eingebaute Text-to-Speech.
Und das ist irgendeine japanische Text-to-Speech-API, die wir im Hintergrund verwenden.
Die gibt es nirgendwo, die Files. Die werden erzeugt hier.
Das sind keine Files. Das ist von japanischen Text-to-Speech-API.
Man kann auch Files reinmachen. Zum Beispiel der Camera-Dude.
Das ist ein Waff-File, das ich reingezogen habe. Aber die anderen Sachen sind dynamisch erzeugt von der Text-to-Speech-Engine.
Voice-Text. Genau, Voice-Text ist es. Ja, also so viel zum Thema Stadia.
Ich probiere es mal aus. Aber die können auch nicht zaubern.
Das hatten wir schon. Dann sind die deutschen Titel auch in Englisch. Ach, man kann mehrere Sprachen dazu, wusste ich gar nicht. Ich habe eh alles auf Englisch stehen, immer.
Ich finde, dass Google ihre Projekte nicht gut weiterführt. Ah ja, das finde ich auch.
Habe ich seit zwei Jahren Google Home. Ja, das ist das Problem.
Habt ihr das mit Nest mitbekommen?
Die hatten, das sind so Thermostat-Dinger, sowas da, so Dinger, was vor allem in den USA recht beliebt war. Und die hatten bisher, die hatten die ganze Zeit schon Probleme,
dass die App, dass die Nest-Cloud öfters mal ausgefallen ist. Und wenn die Nest-Cloud ausgefallen ist, konnten die Leute ihre Heizung nicht mehr einstellen.
Was schon echt übelster Pepega-Scheiß ist. Wenn du deine eigene Heizung nicht mehr einstellen kannst, weil Nest gerade nicht erreichbar ist.
Zumindest Google hat sich gedacht, wir setzen der Sache jetzt noch die Krone auf. Und zwar schalten wir die Nest-AP einfach ab.
Das heißt, alle, die irgendwelche Nest-Integrationen haben, alle, die irgendwelche Heimautomatisierungs-Sachen haben, alle, die ja mit irgendwas machen,
können es nicht mehr machen, weil Google gesagt hat, nee, Nest-AP kommt weg.
Das ist halt richtig, ja.
Deswegen kaufe ich mir so ein Kram auch nicht. Und ja, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, ich finde auch, dass Google viele Sachen macht,
auch mit riesem Tamtam macht, und im Nachhinein die Sachen aber irgendwie merkwürdig oder halbherzig macht. Ich meine, guckt euch Google Plus an.
Google Plus war von Anfang an ein absoluter Bullshit. Also, nee, stimmt nicht. Nicht Google Plus an sich. Über Google Plus an sich kann man sich streiten.
Die Zwangsintegration mit YouTube zum Beispiel war übelster Bullshit. Das war das Bescheuerste, was die auf YouTube je gemacht haben.
Bescheuerter als sogar die Design-Endung. Aber Google Plus Zwangsintegration war der größte Bullshit ever.
Du konntest von heute auf morgen nicht mal ordentlich Nachrichten schreiben. Kann man dich irgendwie direkt anschreiben?
Ja, kannst du machen. Du kannst mir an meine Business-E-Mail, also falls du hast, weiß ich nicht, was du schreiben willst,
kannst du an meine Business-E-Mail schreiben. Meine Business-E-Mail findest du hier, unter, auf meinem YouTube-Channel,
und zwar unter Kanal-Info. Da, kannst du dann draufklicken und dann siehst du die. YouTube-Channel ist verlinkt auf der Profilseite.
Huge. Falls es aber um irgendwelche technischen Fragen geht oder so, dann Haus in dem Stream-Stat. Dafür ist das ja nicht gedacht.
By the way, ist Buchstabenkopieren so ein Tick von dir? Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1. Ah ne, passt. Die Leute haben es schon verlinkt.
Willst du dir mal wieder ein Postfach anlegen? Ne, das geht ja in Deutschland nicht so ohne Weiteres. Ohne echten Namen und sowas.
Wenn schon, lass ich das dann mal vielleicht irgendwann übers Netzwerk machen oder so. Eigentlich nicht.
Boah, das ist eben ein bisschen kaputt.
Wir müssen uns, wenn eine Störung ist laut SLA, einmal von Berlin nach Frankfurt teleportieren. Ja, SLA, das stimmt. Das hat teilweise oftmals mit der Realität wenig zu tun. Kommt doch immer nur im Ernstfall darauf an, ob sich einer verklagt deswegen.
Ja und Zuschauer bin ich tatsächlich schon über den Weg gelaufen. Einmal auf der Gamescom natürlich, da ist das öfters passiert, was das Leute erkannt haben. Am lustigsten war es, wo wir Battlefield, damals was war das, Battlefield Hardline-Probe gespielt haben.
Auf der Gamescom und die haben noch, in Hardline gab es noch diesen, ich nenne es mal diesen Rainbow Six Modus, wo man 5 gegen 5 gespielt hat, verteidigen und die fanden dieser CS Modus, dieser Fake CS Modus.
Und da waren wir halt zusammengewürfelt im Team und ich hab dann halt gesagt, auf einmal irgendwie so mitten in der Runde hab ich gesagt, ey Jungs, wir sucken übelst oder so. Und dann kam dann danach hier mal zu mir und hat gefragt, sag mal, bist du Max FPS von Youtube?
Das hat sich zu nach Max angehört, wo ich gesagt hab, wir sucken, Alter, wir sucken. Kamerangestellst, ja. Und auf der Arbeit hab ich auch schon zwei Azubis. Enttarend.
Ja, aber gut, wenn es ja nix wild ist. Revealed, genau. Revealed wurde er hier. Revealed wurde ich doch schon, wo ist es?
Hier, Revealed wurde ich doch schon damals, 2013 in dem Video.
Da weiß man es. Seit da weiß man es, ja. Direkt liegt. Ich mein, ich erkenn mich da drauf, ja. Aber jemand anderes durch.
Du bist aber ziemlich verzerrt. Alter, willst du mich beleidigen oder was? Ich seh halt nur mal so aus. Anzeige ist raus. Was haben wir sonst noch für Fragen?
Meinung zu Google One. Ist Google One nicht das Smartphone von denen? Nee, was war Google One? Ach, da, ach, das, das, das, das, das Laufwerk, Moment. Google One? Nee, das ist wieder was anderes, oder?
War One nicht Microsoft? OneDrive? Das war doch Microsoft. Sag mal, können die sich mal ordentliche Namen ausdenken?
In dem einen TV-Video von denen sieht man mich ganz gut. Es gibt ein paar Videos, wo man mich ganz gut sieht. Es gibt sogar irgendwo ein Video von dem Battlefield 1 Event, wo ich in der Ecke stehe und man mich komplett sieht, aber keiner hat gecheckt, dass ich das bin.
Warum nennen die das Google One und warum heißt das OneDrive? Das ist schon wieder Verwirrung vorprogrammiert. Google One ist, ist das neu oder was? Die haben doch schon, also Google Cloud Speicher gibt es doch schon eine Weile.
Was gibt es denn da? Jede Menge Platz. Wie viel? Ach, hier. Auto ist aber ziemlich günstig.
Na, wobei. Wobei. Lass mal überlegen. 20 Euro im Jahr. Was sind denn so die, was sind denn so? Warte mal, was? Was kosten das da? Die sind doch recht beliebt für Backup-Geschichten. Unbegrenzte Datensicherung, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Es gab doch auch so einen ZFS-Backup-Anbieter. Was hat denn das da gekostet? R-Sync, genau, war das das? Was kosten denn hier die Gigabyte?
Jetzt immer voll Other Pricing. Das ist nicht richtig beschrieben. Ich kann es gar nicht richtig einschätzen, ob 100G mittlerweile gut oder schlecht sind für 2 Euro im Monat. Bauchgefühl würde ich sagen, das ist eigentlich relativ günstig, aber so wirklich sicher bin ich mir nicht.
Und die Sache ist die, wie kann man drauf zugreifen? Geht das nur offiziell über die App? Geht das nur über das Webinterface? Oder kann man sogar sich das Laufwerk irgendwie unter Lilux mounten oder so?
Das wäre natürlich richtig geil, wenn man das als Netzlaufwerk verwenden könnte, weil da kann man doch ordentlich Backups drauf machen.
Was, Musik, Grip? Geht doch noch alles. Außer, dass die Musik sackt.
Also 2 Euro für 100G ist dagegen schlecht, okay. Wir gucken mal, was man aktuell bei Hetzener Server Auktion bekommen würde an Speicherplatz für ein System, wenn man das selbst bauen will.
Das ist nicht das billigste, ist klar. Aber schauen wir mal, was würde man so aktuell kriegen?
Haben wir mal Preis im Monat, sagen wir mal 20 Euro. Yes, ich agreee. HDD Size, haben wir das jetzt irgendwie? Irgendwie sieht die Seite anders aus als das letzte Mal.
Data Center ist mir egal. Auktionen. Capacity, konnte man das nicht früher mal sortieren?
Also 6TB für 30 Euro im Monat. Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Allerdings, na doch, das ist okay. Guckt mal, 6TB für 30 Euro, das ist billiger als Google Drive.
Also wenn sogar die Hetzener Server Auktion billiger ist als Google Drive, also hier kriegste für 3 Euro, sagen wir mal so, wenn du das jetzt einfach mal verschieben würdest, dann kosten 600GB 3 Euro, was immer noch viel günstiger ist als bei Google.
Gut, man muss sich selbst darum kümmern, aber unterm Strich ist das hier eigentlich in der Regel teurer als bei einem Storage-Anbieter. Das heißt, das lohnt sich nicht so richtig, nicht so tolle.
Aber vor einer Weile gab es doch die Möglichkeit, dass man sich einen YouTube Premium-Account oder irgendwie so einen Family-Account oder irgendwie sowas war das doch macht, wo man dann quasi noch andere User mit anmelden kann und dann war das doch angeblich richtig billig.
Erinnere mich da irgendwie dran.
Insomniac Dude, ich würde mir erstmal belegen, ob du wirklich 300GB Backup hast, also ob das wirklich das Notwendige ist.
Und dann müsste ich mal gucken, weil ich bin aktuell auch nicht mehr auf dem Laufenden, was gute Server-Anbieter angeht.
Hetzener Storage Boxes, stimmt, was gibt es denn da?
Na so geil ist das jetzt alle, oder?
Terabyte für 10€? War schon teuer.
Na gut, okay, Moment, man hat ja auch Zugriff per SSH, per SSH, dafür ist es gar nicht mal übel. Das ist fix und fertig und du kannst direkt mit ordentlichen Tools draufsinken und Backupen. Kannst WebDAF Mountain, kannst Borg Backupen, kannst Samba Mountain, dafür ist es gar nicht schlecht.
Okay, 10€ ist schon mal recht ordentlich.
Also früher haben sie immer auf Reddit und so haben sie den hier empfohlen. Ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt aktuell ist hier, Simple Pricing, Unlimited Data. Früher haben sie den hier immer für Backup empfohlen auf Reddit, habe ich aber nie verwendet.
Samba Mountain übers Internet, na ja, YOLO. Was kostet denn das hier? Personal Backup, ja. 6€ im Monat. Und wie viel Speicher ist das?
Sieht das jemand, wie viel Speicher das jetzt ist? Achso, das ist auch ganz cool, wenn man restoren muss, dann kann man es sich per USB schicken lassen oder per Platte zuschicken lassen.
Dropbox, 2TB, 10€ im Monat, ja das ist doch... Also ich weiß nur, dass sie den auf Reddit früher immer empfohlen haben. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt aber nicht genau warum, wenn ich mir das so angucke.
6€ im Monat, pro Computer. Ist das Unlimited? Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Unlimited für 6$ im Monat. Das wäre natürlich echt gut, ja. Also Unlimited ist wahrscheinlich, ne, Unlimited.
Also so fake Unlimited, genauso Unlimited wie Vodafone. Vodafone, habt ihr das? Unlimited.
Vodafone hat auch letztens wieder irgendwelche Leute rausgeschmissen, weil sie Unlimited wörtlich genommen haben.
Die... Achja Amazon, Amazon hatte ja auch mal... War das nicht O2? Das kann auch O2 gewesen sein. Das könnten auch einfach beide gewesen sein.
Weil das traue ich jedem Anbieter zu. Freenet, das nicht mittlerweile. Freenet ist doch irgendwas anderes, gehört doch irgendetwas. Freenet ist doch eins und eins, oder?
War das Freenet hier? Achja hier, das da. Freenet, Königskunden mit hohem Datenverbrauch. Ich denke es wäre halt mal sinnvoll, dass man regelt, was Flatrate eigentlich bedeutet.
Weil aktuell schreiben sie alle Flatrate drauf und es ist im Endeffekt keine. Es wäre doch für alle Beteiligten besser zu wissen, was Sache ist, ja. Und wenn zu mir einer sagt, hey, du hast einen 500 Gigabyte Tarif, dann weiß ich es in 500 Gigabyte und ich weiß auch, dass es mir reicht.
Aber das wäre echt gut. Also wenn die Unlimited auch halbwegs ernst meinen für 6 Euro im Monat, kann man sich beschweren. Ich weiß aber halt auch nicht, ob man dismounten kann richtig, wie das funktioniert.
Offside Backup steht ja bei mir auch schon länger auf dem Plan, dass ich mir mal was Gescheites überlege. Aber ich hab noch nichts Gescheites gemacht in der Richtung.
Aktuell geht mein Backup auf meine Kiste hier, die hinter mir steht. Mit den dreimal 10TB Platten drinnen, also 20TB ZFS RAID 1 ist das. Und da hab ich genug Speicherplatz mehr als ich überhaupt irgendwie brauche hier.
Und da mach ich meine Backups drauf und ich lösche ja die Dateien auch nicht bei mir irgendwie jetzt auf dem Rechner. Das heißt, ich hab die dann eh immer mehrfach. Und die ganz wichtigen Sachen hab ich sogar immer in Nextcloud gesyncht.
Mein Keypass, Passwortfile und so Zeug. Homewell, ja das stimmt. Allerdings will man die Platten aus dem RZ gar nicht unbedingt daheim haben. Weil die die ausgemustert werden im RZ, die sind meistens nicht die größten und nicht das was man daheim im Nass haben will.
Dann hast du dann irgendwelche ollen 15K SAS Platten mit keine Ahnung was haben die so 320G oder irgendwie sowas. Ich weiß nicht was die Dinger da haben die man gerade ausmistet. Das will man eigentlich daheim gar nicht unbedingt im Nass verwenden.
Wobei RZ Rabatt ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt. Ich hab auch schon ein paar ausgemusterte Sachen hier bei mir eingebaut. Zum Beispiel die Quadport Intel Netzwerkkarte ist bei uns aus dem RZ, die wurde ausgemustert.
Und dann hab ich noch zwei Dualport Netzwerkkarten die wurden aus dem RZ ausgemustert und noch ein paar Glasfaserkabel für 10G Netzwerk. Die haben wir auch ausgemustert. Hab ich auch ein paar abgreifen können.
Ja. Ausrufezeichen PC. Tatsächlich so ein Kommando haben wir. Wusste ich gar nicht. Ist das überhaupt der richtige PC? Ja, ist der richtige PC. Interessant. Wusste ich gar nicht das wir ein Kommando für einen aktuellen PC haben.
Meinung zu Facebook Libra kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Okay.
Hä? Ich konnte schon immer über Localhost auf WSL zugreifen. Oder was meinst du damit jetzt?
WSL geht auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung und Dualboot dauert aber noch ein bisschen bis man das ordentlich verwenden kann. Du kannst zum Beispiel nichts gescheites mounten und sowas. Copy und Paste ist auch so eine Sache für sich. Schön finde ich es nicht.
Weil Dualboot zu lange dauert. Deswegen ist das beste was man machen kann. Einfach Windows mit Linux VM. Beste. Windows mit Linux VM. Einfach auf einem Desktop die Linux VM und auf dem anderen Desktop Windows. Das ist das beste was es gibt. Das ist dann auch ein vollständiges Linux ohne dass man WSL braucht. Einfach besser.
Error X. Abonnier Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. Nice.
Das hört sich so geil an. Moment das hier.
Wie lange sind wir jetzt schon? 1,5 Stunden. Also wie gesagt kein Dualboot. Quatschner. Twitch Prime. Übrigens. Dankeschön Quatschner. Auch hier. Nice.
Ultra nice. Was ich gerade sagen wollte. Wenn ihr ausseht geht es aber ab hier. Xenon 420. Dankeschön. Nice.
Was für eine VM kannst du empfehlen vor allem bei Workstation. Es geht allerdings auch mit Virtual Box. Geht theoretisch auch mit Hyper V würde ich mal sagen. Hab ich ja nie ausprobiert.
Aber vor allem bei Workstation ist für mich die rundeste Lösung unter Windows. Kannst du die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen? Die Musik ist eigentlich ziemlich leise. Die kann sich bloß irgendwie nicht entscheiden ob sie leise oder laut ist.
Guck jetzt gehts wieder voll ab. Fuck. Weil warum Wengar Boys? Was ist denn mit Wengar Boys zu tun? Achso das war das was ich davor laufen hatte.
So jetzt hab ich mal ein bisschen leiser gemacht. Jetzt müsste es passen.
Wo ist denn das Meme Tool? Ah nein nicht unbedingt. Wobei. Könnte man eigentlich machen.
Probieren wir mal aus. Ob das funktioniert. Also da müssen wir Youtube Download machen. Youtube Download. Kann euch mal zeigen wie ich das mache. Minus F. Kann man sich das Format anzeigen lassen.
So und jetzt wollen wir haben. Das Format will ich eigentlich nur die Audio Datei haben. Davon nur die Audio Datei.
Hacks und Tricks jetzt. So nur die Audio Datei runterladen von dem Video. Was 140? Warum 140? Ah 140 ja ihr habt recht. 140 will ich haben nicht 100.
Weil warum will ich 140 haben? Weil 140 ist 130k Audio und das andere ist so 50k Audio. Das suckt. Besser. Jetzt können wir Youtube Video runterladen.
Also jetzt haben wir uns nur die Audio Spur vom Youtube Video runtergeladen. Können wir jetzt mal testen ob das funktioniert. VLC aufmachen das ganze einfach.
Dann sollte das einfach. Alter. Funktioniert. Und jetzt haben wir FFmpeg. Wir konvertieren das einfach zu gebated.waff.
Minus I. So. Und jetzt gehen wir in mein Board. Gebatet. Jetzt gehen wir in mein Board und ziehen das da rein. Und sagen Upload.
Und hoffen das es funktioniert weil die Datei ziemlich groß ist. Hat das jetzt funktioniert? Sieht nicht so aus oder? Ich glaube die Datei ist zu groß.
Ich glaube weil es gebated schon gibt. Und die Datei ist zu groß. Es backt rum wenn die Datei so groß ist. Geht nicht.
Darf ich vielleicht als mp3? Darf man als mp3? Jetzt vielleicht als mp3?
Nee die Datei ist einfach zu lang. Das geht ja 10 Minuten. Ich muss das kürzen. Ich muss das auf jeden Fall kürzen. Sonst spielt das 10 Minuten gebated ab.
Muss das kürzer machen. Wie macht man das mit FFmpeg? Skip? Only 10 seconds.
Ja. Skip. Beste. Probably passed. So und jetzt haben wir gebated 3. Geht nur 10 Sekunden. So jetzt sollte es besser funktionieren denke ich.
Ah. Jetzt funktioniert es. Biste. Hab ich doch kein missprogrammiert.
Nee keine Animation. Da kann ich nichts anderes einblenden. Ja aber jetzt haben wir es so ein bisschen sidetracken lassen bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Ich mach das noch etwas leiser. Das ist leider nicht so ported. Das müsste ich mit FFmpeg irgendwie leiser machen. Ich hab hier noch kein. Ich müsste hier einen Audio Slider noch einbauen.
Wie formuliere ich das denn jetzt? Make sound louder. Was ist denn das Gegendeil von louder?
More silence. Decrease. Aha. FFmpeg kann alles. Half volume. FFmpeg kann einfach alles.
Ok löschen wir das mal wieder. Gebated ist weg. Also ich muss sagen mein Meme Board funktioniert mittlerweile echt ganz ok.
Hier gebated 4. Gucken wir mal ob es jetzt leiser ist. Ist das jetzt leiser? Ja ist leiser ne. Ist leiser.
Hast du nochmal was dran gemacht? Nö. Ist immer noch die Version von vor einem Jahr oder so.
Das ist allerdings nicht so ganz einheitlich laut.
Na gut. Genau drauf gebastelt. Soll ich noch was offen? Das stimmt. Da weiß ich allerdings vom besten Willen nicht wie ich das in FFmpeg gescheit mache.
Müssen wir erstmal suchen danach. Nee hab ich nichts dran gemacht. Wie gesagt vor allem der Workstation würde ich empfehlen.
Es macht für mich den rundesten Eindruck. Hat das einen Grund warum du nicht Wasser kühlst? Wirklich einen Grund hat das nicht. Nee.
Ich hab mich früher nie so richtig an Wasserkühlung ran getraut. Mittlerweile ist das ja kein Ding wenn du dir so ein all in one Ding holst.
Da muss man sich ja nicht mehr großartig ran trauen. Das ist ja fix und fertig.
Und bis jetzt hab ich es noch nicht ausprobiert. Also hat keinen Grund warum ich nicht Wasser kühle. Keinen rationalen und erklärbaren Grund.
Achso für die Hintergrundmusik. Ja gut.
Das ist aber halt nicht die Hintergrundmusik. Das ist halt das komplette Desktop Audio. Also auch Spielesound und so.
Was? Why you shouldn't water cool your PC? Von Linus Tech Tips. Da hat er wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwelche komischen Dinge gemacht.
Es gibt ganz viele Leute die im PC Wasser kühlen. Ich kenne auch jede Menge mittlerweile. Die meisten würde ich fast sagen haben es zumindest schon mal ausprobiert.
Die ich kenne die halt auch Technik interessiert sind. Ist das Kompilieren in einer VM nicht auch langsamer als ein Tief Linux laufen zu lassen?
Na ja. Theoretisch schon. Praktisch ist das kein großer Unterschied. Also CPU Leistung in einer VM ist ziemlich nah an dem dran was in deinem Host auch möglich ist.
Der einzige Unterschied ist dass du dir oftmals deine VM nicht die kompletten Ressourcen zur Verfügung stellst.
Also beispielsweise für meine VM habe ich ja auch hier eingestellt, dass er nur zwei CPUs von sechs möglichen CPUs kriegt.
Dann ist es natürlich langsamer. Aber wenn du der VM vier Kerne gibst und dein Host kompiliert mit vier Kernen, dann ist der Unterschied nicht sonderlich groß zwischen der VM und wenn du es direkt auf dem Host machst.
So aber Leute ich wollte mir noch den neuesten Super Mario World Speedrun World Rekord angucken.
Nämlich erst einen Monat her habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Übelst Naisu.
Also der atmet aber ganz schön laut.
Moment. Erstmal Sound ausmachen. Da wir gerade beim Kompilieren sind was hältst du denn vom neuen NGAN sinnvoll? Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ach so Moment. Ich habe ich habe mich verlesen. Nicht vom neuen Tool NGAN.
Ich überlege ist das dieses Dokumentation Generator Ding?
Nee das ist was anderes.
Dann kann ich dir dazu nichts sagen.
Und wenn ich Linux in einer VM auf dem Laptop laufen lasse dann zieht das viel Strom oder?
Nö warum sollte das viel Strom ziehen? Das zieht Strom wenn du was machst in einer VM.
VM bei 14 oder 50 ist neueste. Wird das neueste nehmen.
Speedrun gucken.
Also hier Speedrun von. Nicht das wir uns jetzt hier mit fremden Federn schmücken. Das ist von Green Death Flavor. Von vor einem Monat ungefähr entstanden.
Den wollte ich mir schon die ganze Zeit mal angucken.
Half Life Speedruns sind auch übelst krass.
Ich gucke immer Mario World Sachen gerne weil da kommt es so krass auf wie nennen sie das immer Execution an.
Also die resetten ja teilweise schon wenn sie einen Frame zu spät gesprungen sind und sowas.
Ich mein das erste Level ist noch relativ easy.
Allerdings halt nicht.
So wie die das ausführen ja.
Jetzt kommt gleich durch die Wand geklippe. Jetzt klippen sie gleich durch die Wand.
Machen sie nicht. Wurde hier nicht immer durch die Wand geklippt sonst.
Ich dachte man klippt hier nochmal.
Ah er redet. Ist ja logisch.
Ich dachte man klippt da durch die Wand.
Schau ein bisschen Musik an.
Ich mein das ist schon übelst nice und das sind auch die easy Levels.
Ach stimmt das ist bei Any% ja hast du recht.
Ich mein die ersten zwei Levels die würde ich mir auch noch zutrauen dass ich die ordentlich hinkriege.
Aber danach hört es auf.
Das geht auch noch irgendwie.
Aber selbst da kommt es halt wahrscheinlich echt drauf an dass du so nach dem Motto beim richtigen Frame zur richtigen Zeit abspringst.
Ich kenne mich von dem Hintergrund her von der Technik her bei Mario World Speedruns nicht sonderlich gut aus.
Aber spätestens in der Festung ist dann vorbei ist dann Schluss.
Also spätestens jetzt ist Schluss mit lustig.
Ich denke auch dass du die ersten drei Levels nicht allzu viel Zeit rausholen kannst.
Aber hier spätestens hier dürfte jetzt Schluss mit lustig sein.
Warum wurde der da nicht gehitted?
Warum wurde der eben nicht gehitted?
Jetzt kommt eine Runde Autoscroller das ist jetzt easy das würde ich jetzt auch wieder hinkriegen.
Und ich wusste gar nicht dass man nicht stirbt wenn man in den Stampfer rein springt.
Ich mein das ist halt übelst nice das würde ich nie so hinkriegen.
Den Typ mal einfach so easy wegzusnacken.
Ich weiß noch wo ich das wo ich klein war zuerst das erste mal gespielt habe.
Ich hab da irgendwie gefühlt eine halbe Stunde gebraucht bis ich das Viech in der Lava hatte.
This is gonna be the run hat man nicht früh geschrieben dass es the urn ist war das nicht früher so gang und gäbe.
Ab jetzt wird es ab jetzt wird es schwieriger.
Ich hab ja schon ein paar 11 exit things runs geguckt die Route ist ja am Anfang immer die gleiche.
Wobei ich gesehen habe dass es jetzt eine neue Route gibt die superschwierig sein soll.
Das krieg ich auch noch hin easy.
Übrigens ich glaub das hier ist das was du am Anfang mit Yoshi und der Münze machst.
Wo du im ersten Level von Yoshi runterspringst dass du hier oben so ein special item kriegst.
Das da.
Ich glaub das ist das rumgeklitsche am Anfang mit Yoshi gewesen dass du hier oben das item kriegst.
Es sieht easy aus die Sache ist halt die wenn du einen Sprung verkackst kannst du resetten.
Ich mein allein schon das dass du das schnell hinkriegst mit dem Schlüssel das ist schon mal nicht ohne.
Ich denk mal ab und zu quasi wenn du dir dann selbst im emulator machst ein level so zu spielen ist kein ding.
Allerdings das konstant am stück so zu spielen ist halt sicher nicht einfach.
Und da hätte ich jetzt schon längst mein cape verloren weil ich in irgendeinem geist hängen geblieben wäre.
Das ist so weich wie die sich bewegen immer.
Das ist übelst nice.
Ich wäre laufen an irgendwelchen Plöcken hängen geblieben.
Da siehst du halt schon dass da teilweise Leute tausend tausend Spielstunden oder so drin haben.
Und da hab ich mir auch richtig schwer getan bei dem bei dem Buu wo ich klein war.
Hallo nacho Libre ee ee ee
Ach man kann also ok easy easy.
Jetzt kommen die schwer an levels.
Ja das das das würde ich auch hinkriegen das würde ich auch hinkriegen da oben mit dem joshi lang zu schwimmen.
Aber muss man den joshi nicht füttern.
Nee der verwendet den joshi plus zum plus zum schnell schwimmen.
Ich glaube wenn man ich glaube wenn man den den special exit haben will dann muss man den joshi füttern.
Die Bewegung ist halt so weich da wird nirgendswo hängen geblieben oder irgendwas.
Aber man sieht schon das ist quasi fast optimales movement oder hat das was hast du da mal Sekunde Unterschied.
Ja die einzelnen sachen flo sex und die einzigen sachen sind mit sicherheit auch nicht so schwierig allerdings das konstant hinzukriegen.
Und am stück ist wahrscheinlich das schwierige.
Also die einzelnen sachen zwischendurch geht schon.
Aber wie gesagt der dude muss halt resetten wenn er einmal hängen bleibt.
Also ich würde es nicht auf die reihe kriegen.
Macht doch ein bisschen Speedrun Training.
Ich guck ich bin Speedrun Gucker.
Ich glaube zum selbst Speedrun habe ich nicht die mentale Frust Resistenz die man da so braucht.
Wie ewig ich früher gebraucht habe bei diesem Level.
Der kreisel sich da einfach mal so durch.
Genau dafür hat er am Anfang mit joshi rumgeklitscht dass er jetzt die wolke kriegt.
Stimmt genauso war das ich erinnere mich wieder.
Weil du bist mit der wolke in dem fight viel schneller.
Und normalerweise sollst du hier keine wolke haben.
Und normalerweise kannst du auch keine wolke da in deinem Power Up Ding storen.
Das geht nur wenn du im ersten Level mit joshi rumgeklitscht hast.
Wieso verliert er seinen Umhang nicht?
Solange du Spin Jumps verlierst du deinen Umhang nicht wenn du getroffen wirst glaube ich.
Solange du fliegst verlierst du deinen Umhang nicht wenn du getroffen wirst.
Genau dann wirst du bloß aus dem fliegen raus geworfen.
Jetzt ist er eskaliert.
Da freut sich einer.
Mario sieht ein bisschen verbackt aus.
Ja pock.
Der ist voll aus dem häuschen.
Der eskaliert ja voll.
Der ist ja fast am weinen.
Aber kann ich verstehen.
Guck mal 2043 Anläufer hat das gebraucht.
Kann ich verstehen dass man danach ein bisschen fertig mit den Nerven ist.
Irgendjemand hat geschrieben Half Life Speedruns sind auch übelst krass.
Das stimmt.
Es gab glaube ich auch letztens ein Half Life Rekord wenn ich mich nicht irre.
Genau vor 14 Tagen.
Ne doch scriptless genau.
Vor 14 Tagen gab es einen neuen Rekord.
Das habe ich mitgekriegt weil ich zufällig im ESA Stream letztens Half Life geguckt habe.
Und da saß halt der Typ mit dem Rekord.
Ist auch übelst heftig.
Es ist übelst heftig wie Half Life Speedruns aussehen.
Das ist echt krass.
Moment kann man da die Auflösung ein bisschen hoch stellen.
Die Auflösung ein bisschen hoch.
Das ist übelst krass Half Life Speedruns.
Was ich übrigens auch toll finde dass die irgendwie ohne 3D Beschleunigung spielen.
Rein in Software.
Guck mal wie du alleine durch das erste Level durchsaust.
Und vor allem das Gras halt nicht hängen bleibt.
Ich glaube jeder der Half Life gespielt hat.
Half Life 1 und Half Life 2.
Und in Half Life 2 ist es noch viel schlimmer.
Hat das Problem dass er permanent an irgendeinem Shit hängen bleibt.
Generell finde ich wo sich richtig gute Speedrunner unterscheiden von nicht so guten Speedrunnern.
Und von Casual Gamer.
Ist halt eindeutig wenn du siehst wie weich sich die Leute durch die Levels bewegen.
Da merkst du halt die haben schon Erfahrungen mit wo ein Schrank hängt oder wo irgendwas ist.
Da wird nicht hängen geblieben da wird exakt.
Das ist echt nice.
Und das ist ja noch quasi Intro.
Vor allem wie eckig die Dinger in Half Life ausgeschaut haben damals.
Achso übrigens hier.
Das ist das Speedrunner.
Das ist Key.
Und das siehst du in allen Games.
Was die Sachen rausreißt ist hauptsächlich das Movement.
Bei nahezu allen Speedruns die man so sieht.
Also der Unterschied zwischen den besten und denen die danach kommen.
Ist hauptsächlich wie sich bewegt wird in den Games.
Und dazu zählt natürlich auch wie konsistent man irgendwelche Glitches hinkriegt.
Wenn man sich überlegt wie schwer man sich am Anfang getan hat.
Beispielsweise in Mario 64 diese ganzen Back Dings Bums Long Jumps dazu machen.
Und wie konsistent das die Leute heute teilweise hinkriegen.
Ist schon krass also da steckt verdammt viel Übung drin.
Gut das ist jetzt Intro, Half Life Intro.
Richtig anfangen tut es eigentlich ja erst hier.
Aber man sieht schon auch es ist noch recht entspannt.
Hä hängt das?
Ah nee er bewegt sich noch einfach nicht.
Genau hier irgendwo geht es los.
Und es gibt wohl gleich am Anfang in den Glitch dass du diese Zwischensequenz überspringen kannst.
Es gibt ja am Anfang diese Zwischensequenz die eigentlich jetzt gleich kommt.
Wo du von diesem Blitz von diesem Experiment getroffen wirst.
Und dann kommt diese Xen Zwischensequenz.
Und das kann man irgendwie skippen wenn man es richtig macht.
Anscheinend so irgendwie.
Wie auch immer.
Wie auch immer es funktioniert ich habe keine Ahnung.
Es gibt die Zwischensequenz.
Und normalerweise ist man halt hier mit einem Drittel des Speeds irgendwie unterwegs.
Achja und man kann irgendwie auch saven und loaden.
Wenn man in irgendwas reinspringen würde was jetzt eigentlich explodiert.
Dann loadet man und das passiert irgendwie nichts.
Gibt es eigentlich News von Black Mesa die meinten ja mal dass die Xen Levels fast fertig sind.
Ja die sind also in der Beta die Xen Levels.
Endless Dimension.
Ja stimmt genau so wie das ist.
Ich kenne mich damit auch nicht großartig aus.
Ich habe bloß halt ein paar Flyer Speedruns geguckt.
Mir ein paar Sachen gemerkt die die Leute so erzählt haben.
Das ist echt nice.
Das hier ist jetzt ja noch alles relativ relativ gradlinig.
Also an der Stelle das ist der Weg den man normalerweise auch als Casual Spieler nimmt.
Nur halt ein bisschen schneller.
Aber ich meine okay das ist vielleicht also prinzipiell ist es der Weg den man als Casual Spieler nimmt.
Allerdings jetzt vielleicht nicht so in diese Art und Weise.
Vor allem schon mal gar nicht in der Geschwindigkeit.
Das hier schon mal nicht.
Die haben jetzt ein komplettes Level übersprungen.
Normalerweise käme da jetzt dieser Fahrstuhl Kletterpart.
Die haben jetzt quasi irgendwie sich ein Level weiter geklitscht.
Dadurch dass sie gespeichert haben vor dem Fahrstuhl.
Wahrscheinlich ist in dem Fahrstuhl das haben sie ja in Half-Life damals.
Ich rate jetzt mal ein bisschen.
Wie gesagt ich habe ja von internen Detail.
Ich habe in Half-Life selbst nie gespeedrunn oder so.
Was sie in Half-Life gerne gemacht haben ist dass du zwischen zwei Türen hattest du quasi Level Übergang Trigger.
Also Level Übergänge.
Und wahrscheinlich kannst du wenn du quasi den Level Übergang auslöst allerdings rausgehst landest du wahrscheinlich in einem anderen.
Und die haben jetzt quasi die komplette Fahrstuhl und Office Sequenz übersprungen.
Normalerweise käme da ein ganzes Level dazwischen.
Oder kommt das jetzt mit dem Fahrstuhl und dem Office?
Nee das ist jetzt Office und Fahrstuhl.
Oder? Ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Es passiert zu viel.
Es ist zu viel los.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Ist das jetzt Office?
Nee das ist nach Office.
Das ist nicht mehr Office.
Ja der hat Office übersprungen.
Ich check es nicht.
Das ist zu viel.
Zu viel auf einmal.
Nee jetzt kommt der Fahrstuhl und Office.
Alter was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung.
Gibt das wenn es fertig ist?
Oh mein.
Das ist definitiv nicht so gedacht normalerweise.
Normalerweise musst du hier einmal komplett im Kreis durch das Level laufen.
Jetzt kannst du direkt was kommen. Das ist Plast Pit genau.
Das ist mit diesem Tentakel Ding in der Mitte.
Also jetzt hat er auf jeden Fall ein komplettes Level übersprungen.
Plast Pit ist das mit dem Tentakel und der Rakete in der Mitte.
Kann sich wahrscheinlich jeder daran erinnern da Half Life gespielt hat.
Und man läuft gefühlt irgendwie.
Hier unten sieht man glaube ich die Geschwindigkeit von ihm.
Normalerweise bist du halt viel viel langsamer.
Und normalerweise fährst du hier auch mit so einem Auto lang.
Fährst mit so einem Auto lang und das bremst dann hier und dann fliegst du hier drüber.
Der denkt sich halt Yolo wozu einfach durch die Suppe durch.
Was er jetzt macht keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich dass er mit möglichst viel Leben durch die Suppe kommt.
Endless Dimension runnst du selbst Half Life?
Oder ist das einfach auch nur Wissen aus Speedruns die du gekuckt hast?
Normalerweise geht man hier auch außen rum.
Es gibt am Ende noch einen Klitsch wo du unendlich Leben kriegst.
Das kommt aber erst kurz vor dem Lambda Komplex.
Also kurz vor dem letzten Drittel.
Das ist jetzt halt auch nice was kommt.
Normalerweise will das Game von dir dass du quasi bei jedem dieser Dinger hier einmal reingehst und irgendwas machst.
Wobei du musst das machen aber du kannst die Sachen halt auch überspringen.
Normalerweise musst du durch die Türen in der Mitte.
Und ich glaube bei den Türen ist auch nochmal eine Ladezone.
Weil in der Mitte sind diese komischen Tentakeldinger an die sich wahrscheinlich jeder Half Life Spieler erinnern kann.
Normalerweise hätte er da schon einmal durchgemust aber hat gedacht wir überspringen das jetzt einfach mal.
Jetzt kommt der Generator genau.
Das ist alles jetzt noch relativ wie auch immer er das überlebt hat hier das Runterspringen.
Wahrscheinlich wenn du auf irgendeiner schrägen Fläche runter kommst oder sowas.
Wieso kriegt er keinen Fallschaden?
Na manchmal kriegt er Fallschaden, stirbt und reloadet.
Ich denke mal es liegt daran es ist ein bisschen wie CS Surfing.
Das ist wenn du auf einer schrägen Fläche runter kommst.
Und die schräge Fläche ist halt bei den Surfmaps relativ groß.
Und hier war halt die schräge Fläche so ein Zentimeter großer Schalter.
Aber es war eine schräge Fläche.
Ich weiß nicht wie es genau funktioniert die Surfmechanik aber es ist grundlegend das gleiche.
Ja aber das spart halt Zeit.
Normalerweise müsstest du einmal komplett neue Zone laden in der Mitte und durch dieses Tentakelding durchgehen.
Das ist halt super weiches Movement.
Das ist richtig geil zu sehen.
Da wird nirgendwo hängen geblieben.
Das geht wenn gestoppt wird dann nur wenn eine Tür im Weg ist die halt einfach nicht schneller aufgeht.
Prop Jumping gibt es ja in Half Life 1 nicht. Oder? Du kannst ja keine Props nehmen und drauf rumjumpen.
Das spoofen das ist übelst krass ja.
Es sieht mega easy aus.
Es sieht einfach nur so aus als wird er quasi geradeaus laufen und die Maus ein bisschen drehen.
Wer mal versucht hat in CS 1.6 ein bisschen zu Bunny Hoppen.
Das ist ähnlich es ist gar nicht einfach.
Ich glaube mittlerweile würde ich das auch gar nicht mehr hinbekommen.
Du musst links und rechts draven und irgendwie die Maus richtig bewegen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr wie es genau funktioniert aber ich habe schon Probleme gehabt geradeaus zu Bunny Hoppen in CS.
Jetzt muss er zu den Tentakeln.
Normalerweise hättest du bei diesen Tentakeln dreimal durchgemust oder zweimal durchgemust.
Dreimal jetzt muss er noch zurück dreimal durchgemust.
Holt er sich jetzt noch den Health Boost ab?
Ja jetzt gibt es noch einen Health Boost.
Er gibt einem jetzt einen Spritzer der Typ.
Man hat es nicht gesehen er hat die Rakete ausgelöst oben was die Tentakel weg brennt.
Man kann den Button drücken durch die Scheibe.
Normalerweise spielt man das ganz anders.
Wenn man das casual mäßig spielt musst du in den Raum rein drückst auf den Knopf.
Dann startet der Raketen Booster und du kannst nicht aus dem Raum raus.
Das ist quasi an der Stelle wo das Game überhaupt nicht will das er ist.
Also ich will nicht wissen wie viele Stunden der Kerl in Half Life hat das ist krass.
Max Electronics geht mir genau aus ich hatte damals auch übelst Schiss.
Man muss die Epilepsie Warnung aussprechen vor dem Speedrun.
Ach doch du hast rechts.
Ja da hat es gerade geboostet mit den Kisten.
Normalerweise hätte er auch durch das komplette Level laufen müssen.
Also die Mauern zerstörst du normalerweise mit entweder entweder.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher.
Entweder wird die Mauer von dem Endboss den du eigentlich hättest machen müssen davor kaputt gemacht.
Oder du machst die Mauer kaputt mit so einem Rail Auto Ding.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau wie es im Original war.
Aber zumindest ist es nicht gedacht dass du da drüber springst.
Ist das On-Rail schon?
Ist das schon On-Rail?
Das ist überhaupt nicht so gedacht das ist so krass.
Ja das ist On-Rail schon.
On-Rail nur ohne Rail.
Normalerweise fährt man hier mit so einem Auto auf Schienen lang.
Aber da denke ich einfach wozu sollte ich da auf Schienen lang fahren.
Ich kann einfach über die Schienen drüber springen.
Weil normalerweise kriegst du Elektro Damage wenn du auf die Schienen trittst.
Also du kannst da gar nicht so drüber hüpfen.
Jetzt kommt das Raketending.
Das ist echt heftig.
Ich kann es nur erahnen wie schwierig das ist.
Wie gesagt ich habe es im CS nicht mehr geschafft zu Bunny Hoppen.
Geschaltet geradeaus.
Ich überleg mal was sich so eine Wache denkt so nach dem Auto.
Wo ist er hin?
Also Hi Jungs.
Okay anscheinend macht einem da Strom auch nichts wenn man das richtig timet.
Jetzt kommt diese Raketen Start Sequenz.
Normalerweise muss man hier rein.
Da kann ich jetzt etwas zu erzählen.
Weil das habe ich mir schon mal genau angeschaut.
Normalerweise musst du hier unten rein.
Links steht eine Rakete.
Normalerweise musst du hier rein.
Einen Knopf drücken das die Rakete startet.
Er denkt sich aber wozu.
Ich drücke den Knopf einfach von außen.
Allerdings muss er jetzt hinter die Tür.
Weil ich vermute ich mal.
Dann muss ich hier rein.
Weil das sonst gekillt wird von der Rakete draußen.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich weiß nicht warum man hier rein geht.
Eventuell auch einfach zum Helz schnappen bis halt diese Start Sequenz vorbei ist.
Und normalerweise wie gesagt denkt das Game gar nicht dass du draußen bist.
Du stehst normalerweise hier hinter dem da rechts oben was man gesehen hat.
Hier hinter dem da.
Da oben stehst du hinter dem Fenster und guckst raus.
Die treffen ihn gar nicht weil er zu schnell ist.
Jetzt kommt die Geschichte mit dem Fisch.
Da habe ich ja immer noch so ein bisschen Schiss davor.
Weil als ich das das erste Mal gespielt habe.
Ich weiß gar nicht ob man das mit dem Fisch überhaupt sieht.
Weil wo ich das das erste Mal gespielt habe habe ich nicht gecheckt dass da ein Fisch in dem Wasser drinne ist.
Und da fällst du in das Wasser rein.
Auf einmal kommt so ein fetter Fisch und beißt dich.
Das war richtig MonkaS.
Vor dem Level habe ich heute noch ein bisschen Schiss.
Hat ja auch gerade einer geschrieben im Chat.
Dass er vor dem Tentakel Level noch Schiss hatte.
Ich habe vor dem Level habe ich heute noch Schiss in Half Life.
Vor dem Fisch im Wasser.
Hier das da.
Man sieht es gar nicht.
Da kommt so ein riesen Fisch raus der dich auffrisst.
Normalerweise wenn du ins Wasser fällst.
Also außer man überspringt das einfach alles.
Und ich habe es ja schon mal gesagt.
Ich habe eh Schiss vor tiefem Wasser.
Ich habe keine Höhenangst oder sonst was.
Ich habe aber irgendwie Schiss vor tiefem Wasser.
Und ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Das ist für mich übelst MonkaS das Level.
Tiefenangst.
Genau ich weiß gar nicht ob es das Wort gibt.
Ach ja aber übrigens nur wenn ich es nicht sehe.
Im Schwimmbad irgendwie.
Ich habe übelst Schiss.
Früher hatte ich übelst Schiss in das Springbecken rein zu gehen.
Ich hatte kein Schiss vor dem Brett zu springen.
Sondern Schiss vor dem Wasser.
Unter dem Sprungbecken.
Also nein vor dem Wasser im Springbecken.
Nicht vor dem Sprungbrett hatte ich früher Schiss.
Also ich hatte überhaupt keine Probleme von 10m runter zu springen.
Aber ich hatte Schiss lange in diesem Wasser zu schwimmen.
Wo man rein springt.
Komisch oder?
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Bauchgefühlmäßig habe ich das immer noch.
Allerdings wo ich dann lustigerweise keinen Schiss mehr habe ist.
Sobald ich eine Taucherbrille auf habe.
Und in dem gleichen Wasser untergetaucht bin.
Da habe ich dann keinen Schiss.
Dann sehe ich alles.
Aber sobald ich von außen in das Wasser reingucke habe ich übelst Schiss davor.
Wahrscheinlich weil das Licht sich unterschiedlich bricht.
Und es sich viel tiefer aussieht oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Gibt es so Sachen kann man auch nicht unbedingt erklären gut.
Oder sich nicht rational erklären.
So jetzt kommt der Kühlraum.
Wo man eigentlich Damage kriegt.
Wenn man zu lang drinnen ist.
Allerdings ist das so schnell.
Dass er da durch ist.
Jetzt kommt die Assassin Geschichte.
Also normalerweise im nächsten Raum.
Wir werden es im Speedrun wahrscheinlich gar nicht sehen.
Normalerweise im nächsten Raum wird man von so.
Ich glaube von 4 oder 5.
Assassin Grills angegriffen.
Mit Silencer Pistole.
Allerdings anscheinend.
Und das wusste ich auch nicht.
Muss man die Assassin Typen gar nicht.
Oder die Assassin Grills gar nicht bekämpfen.
Sondern kann gleich in den Cutscene Raum rein.
So jetzt kommt die Zwischensequenz.
An die sich wahrscheinlich auch jeder erinnern kann.
Der Half Life man gespielt hat.
Wo man seine ganze Ausrüstung abgenommen kriegt.
Also Storytechnisch wird man jetzt.
Niedergeschlagen worden.
Gefangen genommen worden.
Und kriegt seine ganze Ausrüstung abgenommen.
Und die Wachen unterhalten sich jetzt gerade drüber.
Dass sie hier einfach.
Sie liefern Freeman nicht ab.
Sondern werfen ihn einfach quasi.
In die Schrottpresse.
Dass man den Körper nicht findet.
Es ist halt in der Schrottpresse drin.
Und es ist auch aus der Schrottpresse schon wieder drauf.
Wie.
Was ich damals für einen.
Ich habe es damals überhaupt nicht gecheckt.
Wie man aus der Schrottpresse rauskommt.
Und er springt einfach 2 mal und ist raus.
Easy.
Ja Max Electronics das stimmt.
Für das.
Man muss sagen grafisch.
Grafisch sieht es halt nicht sonderlich immersive aus.
Die ganzen Half Life Geschichten.
Aber was Half Life ausgemacht hat.
War letztendlich, dass du gerade keine Zwischensequenzen.
Im traditionellen Sinn hattest.
Und auch keine Zwischensequenz Videos.
Sondern es war alles Ego Perspektive.
Immer Ingame Grafik.
Du hast glaube ich im kompletten Half Life.
Nicht eine Szene.
Die nicht Ingame Grafik ist.
Ja und Leute es sagt jetzt keiner das Hauptmenü.
Also ich meine wenn man das Spiel gestartet hat.
So das Level mag keiner.
Das ist jetzt hier Hindernis Parkour.
Man kann das bewegen.
Ich wusste überhaupt nicht dass man das bewegen kann.
Das Zeug.
Hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Und wusste gar nicht ob ich das bewegen kann.
Jetzt bricht das Rohr gleich ein.
Macht nichts springt rüber.
Das Movement ist echt übelst.
Next Level.
Und hier hat sich wahrscheinlich auch jeder.
Erstmal verlaufen der Half Life.
Gespielt hat.
Zum ersten Mal gespielt hat.
Und hatte Schiss dass er permanent von irgendwelchen.
Zerquetsch zerdrückt zersonst was wird.
Wie er sich überhaupt nicht für die Gegner interessiert.
So jetzt kommt ein bisschen Parkour Action.
Da war ja Half Life berühmt berüchtigt für.
Was vielen Leuten nicht gefallen hat.
Ich persönlich fand das eigentlich nice.
Jetzt hat er wieder keinen Fallschaden gekriegt.
Weil er auf einem schrägen Untergrund gelandet ist.
Also quasi gesurft.
Dass man einfach drüberspringen kann.
Okay.
Ich glaube jeder von uns hat versucht den Strom auszuschalten vorher.
Der Witz ist ja.
Der ist jetzt nach.
Über die Hälfte vom Game schon fertig jetzt.
An den Part kann ich jetzt gar nicht mehr erinnern wo das ist.
Ach das ist das wo man die Forscher retten muss.
Aus diesem komischen Hackfleisch Ding da.
Weil den Typ braucht man dass er die Tür aufmacht.
Aber normalerweise muss man da doch anders rum durch.
Jetzt holt er sich erstmal seine Waffe.
Nee macht er nicht.
Ich dachte da hinten gibt es diese.
Ich weiß gar nicht wie diese Waffe in Half-Life heißt.
Das Ding was sich dreht und so Laserstrahlen verschießt.
Ja das Ding da.
Wie heißt denn das in Half-Life überhaupt diese Waffe?
Damit kannst du dich boosten.
Wie lange würde man für das Game als Casual brauchen?
Half-Life ist ziemlich lang für einen Ego-Shooter.
Ich würde mal sagen so 7-8 Stunden.
Oder noch länger.
Ich glaube man hat für Half-Life 1 noch länger gebraucht.
Wenn ich mir das angucke was Endless Dimension gepostet hat.
Es ist eher wahrscheinlich dass man 12-14 Stunden braucht.
Oder vielleicht sogar länger.
Half-Life 1 ist eines der längsten Ego-Shooter Games die mir einfallen.
Das hat sehr viele Levels.
Und wenn man denkt es ist fertig geht es noch weiter.
Das hatte ich so in noch keinem anderen Game.
Die meisten anderen Games die ich so spiele.
Denkst du so jetzt passiert mal was geil.
Und dann ist es fertig.
Und in Half-Life war es so du hast gedacht
oh geschafft es ist fertig und dann ging es weiter.
Du hast bei Half-Life hast du zwei Stellen wo du denkst es ist theoretisch fertig.
Einmal wo du gefangen genommen wirst und alle Waffen verlierst.
Das hat damals glaube ich noch kein Game vorher gemacht.
Kein was mir einfällt.
Denkst du oh Scheiße ist vorbei.
So quasi wird fortgesetzt.
Das nächste ist wenn du den Part auf der Erde beendet hast.
Denkst du okay jetzt ist es fertig.
Und das dritte Mal ist wenn es wirklich fertig ist.
Half-Life ist ziemlich lang.
Wenn er überspringt ja auch die meisten Sachen.
Die meisten Räume ist da überhaupt nicht drin die es gibt.
Normalerweise musst du hier einmal komplett im Kreis laufen.
Und die Wissenschaftler holen.
Und den Laser einschalten und alles.
Und erst dann darfst du raus.
Wobei ich eher empfehlen würde Black Mesa zu spielen.
Anstatt das originale Half-Life 1.
Da fuck.
Normalerweise musst du oben rüber über den Damm.
Und noch den Heli killen und sowas.
Und wenn Black Mesa mal die Xen-Levels fertig hat.
Ist das wirklich das bessere Half-Life 1.
Und hier muss man normalerweise auch außen rumlaufen.
Ich finde es auch cool wie gut die Route getimt ist.
Wo er Health Packs aufsammeln kann.
Und wo er sich Damage boostet und sowas.
Normalerweise ist der Boden vermint.
Und man kann da gar nicht langlaufen.
Außer man kennt halt den genauen Weg.
Willst du Black Mesa dann auf Stream zocken?
Ich finde Xen-Levels...
One KS.
The fuck.
Moment das muss ich mir nochmal angucken.
Das war ja nice.
Das war ja echt nice.
Guck mal.
Normalerweise musst du hier unten langlaufen.
Unten langlaufen, da langlaufen.
Nochmal den Heli bekämpfen.
Langlaufen, hochklettern und zurück zum Tunnel.
Und der macht einfach...
The fuck.
Das ist huge Pog.
Ich will nicht wissen wie lange er dafür geübt hat.
Splatter Splatter.
Äh.
Was war das jetzt?
Achso er hat den Fight resettert.
Okay.
Okay wir springen einfach über die Levels drüber.
Okay alles klar.
Jetzt kommt dieses explosive Haus da.
Da wo du normalerweise...
Normalerweise musst du hier...
Das ist ziemlich schwierig dieses Level.
Wenn man das zum ersten Mal spielt.
Dann ist das ganze Lagerhaus komplett...
Mit diesen Laserminen voll.
Und normalerweise ist es in Half-Life ja so.
Du kannst von weitem diese Laserminen auslösen.
Da passiert dir nichts.
Allerdings hier ist das Game halt zu Ende.
Wenn du in die Luft sprengst.
Weil es fliegt das ganze Lagerhaus in die Luft.
Und alter.
Jeder der das das erste Mal spielt.
Das ist eine halbe Stunde bis er durch ist.
Ja YOLO.
Einfach wie das halbe Level übersprungen.
Jetzt musst du die Tür aufschießen.
Normalerweise musst du...
Da war das Lagerhaus noch nicht mal drin.
Und dann kommt...
Echt Pock.
Echt nice.
Okay ich hab keine Ahnung.
Jetzt kommt der unendliche Leben-Klitsch.
Den sieht man eigentlich in jedem Half-Life Speedrun.
Das...
Es funktioniert irgendwie so.
Man sieht hier unten auch seine Heals...
Overflowed.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Aber ich hab mir mal irgendjemand erklärt.
Im Speedrun.
Wenn du eingeklemmt bist.
Man sieht ja hier den Damage-Indikator.
Und knuckelst an einem Heals-Pack.
Oder...
Vielleicht reicht es auch wenn du eingeklemmt bist.
Ich weiß nicht. Dann Overflow deine Heals.
Und da hat jetzt irgendwie keine Ahnung.
8000 Heals oder so.
Und normalerweise soll man hier das Ding in die Luft sprengen.
Man hat da hinten so einen...
So einen Turm.
Mit so einem Artillerie-Geschütz drauf.
Den musst du normalerweise da drauf schießen lassen.
Dass es auch geht.
Ich bin permanent confused wenn ich das sehe.
So jetzt kommen die ganzen Levels.
Die die Militär und Aliens normalerweise bekriegen.
Davon kriegt er aber halt nicht viel mit.
Weil...
Durchrennen.
Weil Speedrun. Jetzt kann er übrigens Damage boosten.
So viel er will.
Weil er hat nicht unendlich Leben.
Aber er hat massig viel Leben.
Das reicht.
Er muss sich jetzt überhaupt keine Gedanken mehr über irgendwie Leben machen.
Wie gesagt hat es irgendwie keine Ahnung.
800.000 Leben oder so. Massig viel Leben.
Reicht. Reicht bis zum Ende des Runs aus.
Jetzt kommen nochmal ein paar Assassin-Grills.
Allerdings werden die einfach auch geskippt.
Half-Life Speedruns sind eines der geilsten Speedruns finde ich.
Erstmal voll mit dem Ding in die Eier geballert.
Als Overflow IRL.
Ja das wäre mal was.
Aber...
Also für dieses Movement hat er...
Hunderte Stunden geübt.
Da hat er hunderte Stunden für geübt.
Ich mein allein schon das Movement was man eben gesehen hat.
Mit diesem Rückwärtsjump.
Er hat wahrscheinlich alles irgendwelche Namen.
Durch die Öffnung.
Durch die Tür. In den Fahrstuhlschacht.
Und normalerweise musst du hier auch...
Bevor du da durch kannst.
Also das muss wohl auch ein Glitch sein.
Dass du es überhaupt aufwisst.
Normalerweise musst du einmal komplett außen rumlaufen.
Den Reaktor einschalten.
Das Kühlsystem einschalten.
Das Kühlsystem überlasten.
Da brauchst du dann normalerweise schon alleine eine Stunde.
Um diese Sektion zu spielen.
Jetzt kommt eine der nervigsten Sachen in Half Life.
Die ihr halt einfach mal überspringt.
Mit einer Granate.
Diese Teleport Einlage im...
Im Teleporter Ding da.
Wie auch immer das heißt.
Da musst du normalerweise von einem Teleporter zum anderen springen.
Jetzt ist kurz ein bisschen Down Time.
Jetzt muss man warten bis die Tür...
Moment warum ist die Tür schon auf?
Normalerweise...
Moment.
Moment Leute.
Normalerweise musst du dir erstmal eine halbe Stunde
den Vortrag anhören.
Normalerweise musst du dir eine halbe Stunde
den Vortrag von den Wissenschaftlern
und den Wachen anhören.
Was Sache ist bevor die die Tür überhaupt aufmachen.
Und dann
musst du normalerweise
wenn du hier in diesen Raum reingehst
musst du da oben steht ein Wissenschaftler drin
den musst du beschützen für glaube ich 3-4 Minuten
vor hier spornenden Aliens
und erst dann
geht der Teleporter auf.
Aber anscheinend
kann man in den Teleporter einfach reinspringen und gut ist.
Easy.
So jetzt wirds übelst abgedreht auf Xen.
Also da wird kein Level so gemacht wie intended.
Teilweise, wobei teilweise schon
das nächste Level wird glaube ich
halbwegs gemacht wie intended.
Nämlich gegen dieses komische
diese Alienkrabbe.
Okay.
Ja Logscrip.
Wie gesagt ich habe
Half-Life selbst nie gerannt. Ich kenne das ja auch nur
vom Runs gucken.
Runt einer von euch Half-Life? Nur mal so gefragt.
Könnte ja sein.
Bei 105 Zuschauern.
Ich glaube das hier
wird halbwegs intended gemacht.
Weil du sonst nicht
weiter kannst.
Wenn das Ding nicht die Netze kaputt macht.
So jetzt kriegt erstmal den Euter in die Luft gesprengt.
Bäm.
Milch ist Gift sage ich da nurzu.
Genau und das musst du jetzt halbwegs wie intended
machen, dass diese Netze, dass das Viech diese Netze
kaputt macht.
Sonst kannst du nicht weiter.
Da sieht man auch mal, dass man da wie man jung war
und das zum ersten Mal gespielt hat
unsinnig Schiss vor diesem Viech gehabt hat.
Das ist nämlich komplett durchgeskriptet
und macht hier zum größten Teil noch nicht mal was.
Damals hast du halt dem Ding
viel mehr KI zugetraut als es eigentlich
hatte.
Und du kriegst auch nicht mal Damage wenn du hier dran
stehst. Du hattest alles das erste Mal gespielt,
aber du hattest es nicht.
Du hattest alles das erste Mal gespielt, du hattest
übelst Schiss.
Ah ja und normalerweise ist es jetzt so gedacht,
dieses Krabbenviech
fällt hier runter und
explodiert quasi, geht kaputt
und der Boden geht kaputt.
Allerdings kann man den Boden auch mit
genug Sprengstoff aufsprengen, was er jetzt
hier macht.
Er braucht halt schon ein bisschen Sprengstoff, dass es
funktioniert. So und jetzt kann er
den Teleporter lange bevor dieses
Alienviech überhaupt da ist.
Ja.
Der hat übrigens gerade wieder mehr oder weniger
das ganze Level geskippt.
Das ist übelst heftig, das Movement.
Wahnsinn.
Jetzt kommt diese Alienfabrik.
Das ist das Level was ich am wenigsten gemacht habe
in Half-Life hier.
Das da.
Oh, er wird
nervös, weil er merkt, dass er nahe
im Weltrekord ist.
Muss er da unten drunter durchkrabbeln?
Ok, das ist die normale Route,
die man so auch nimmt als Casual.
Halt nicht ganz so schnell.
Und das macht man als Casual nicht.
Normal...
Null.
Normalerweise musst du da ewig lange hoch
sein, bis du da bist.
Das dauert eine Stunde oder so,
bis du da oben bist, wenn du das zum ersten Mal
spielst.
Jetzt kommt Endboss.
Ach nee, jetzt muss er erst noch
durch dieses Ding hier drüber, aber jetzt kommt Endboss.
Meinst du,
in diesen Speedruns wird viel gecheatet?
Nö, da wird überhaupt nicht gecheatet.
Keiner, der
bei Sinn ist, cheatet in einem Speedrun.
Erstens, weil es
Beschiss an der ganzen
Community ist und außerdem,
weil du ja, wenn du da irgendwelche Sachen
verwendest, kannst du deinen Speedrun gar nicht einreichen.
Es wird bestimmt versucht zu
bescheißen. Es gab hier letztens diese News drüber,
dass irgendjemand
segmentet hat.
Was war das, ein Super Meat Boy Speedrun glaube ich?
Obwohl es eigentlich am Stück sein sollte.
Aber zum
größten Teil würde ich sagen, ist diese ganze Speedrun
Geschichte eines der
Szenen, wo
es am meisten Skill gibt und am wenigsten
Beschiss.
Ja, und außerdem musst du das eh live
streamen und genau.
Oder zumindest halt
im zusammenhängenden Video zeigen
können. Der Boss ist relativ
easy auch, weil man Casual
spielt, finde ich.
Das Ding hat ganz wirre Hitboxen.
Man denkt, man kann dem nur...
Als Casual denkt man, man muss dem
in den Kopf schießen, muss man aber gar nicht.
Das Game tut nur so.
Jetzt dreht er durch.
Jetzt dreht er ab.
Krasser Run. Echt
krasser Run.
Eine Maus.
Ist weg.
Krasser Run. Echt nice.
Also der kann's.
Wie viel war der
schneller?
Können wir mal gucken.
Der war schneller.
Die Speedrun-Seite
lädt grad nicht.
Der war schneller.
Der war...
20 Sekunden.
Das ist übelst viel.
20 Sekunden, das ist
Spaß.
Also ich vermute zumindest mal, dass das
ziemlich viel sind in diesem High Level
Segment.
Was bedeutet scripted?
Das ist, wenn man keinen Bock hat, die ganzen
Glitches und Tricks zu lernen,
dann kann man das, dann kann man
Skript zur Hilfe verwenden.
Skripted ist quasi
eher was für die,
ich denk mal für Leute,
die nicht
da ihre 1000 Stunden
reinstecken wollen.
Und du hast beispielsweise genau, so wie
es Endes dem Menschen sagt, das Movement ist
halbwegs automatisiert, dass du nicht manuell
bunnyhoppen musst.
Allerdings, der Witz ist, dass
scripted
langsamer ist
als scriptless.
Komisch, oder?
Skripted sollte eigentlich einfacher sein.
Aber das scheint wohl daran zu liegen, dass die
absoluten Top Half Life Runner
eben scriptless runnen und nicht scripted.
Also wenn jetzt hier einer der Top 3
auf die Idee kommen würde, mal
Skripted zu üben, dann wäre der wahrscheinlich
eine ganze Ecke schneller als
als die Skripter Typen.
Skripted mit
SW, habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Gibt es Einschränkungen an Skripte?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wie gesagt,
ich runn selbst kein Half Life und
ich
kenne das auch nur aus Streams, ich weiß es nicht.
Allerdings, man kann sich hier
die haben ja einen Forum, die haben einen Discord und so
und die haben ja auch einen...
Irgendwo kannst du dir auch die Regeln angucken.
Ich finde es schon echt cool, also
das Movement ist echt nicht
von dieser Welt, was
der Kerl da gezeigt hat gerade.
Was? View Rules? Wo?
Ach da!
Ne, das sind die Rules,
weil man was submitten darf, denke ich.
Ja doch, genau.
Ah, hier steht auch was für Skripte
nicht erlaubt sind.
Dass man schneller schießt,
man Damage macht ist nicht erlaubt,
Third Party Makros sind nicht erlaubt,
also wenn ich jetzt mit meiner Makrosoftware von der
Tastatur mache,
oder irgendwelche anderen Dinger.
Autochump, Ducktap,
Autochump, Buck, was auch immer.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gesagt,
ich run das selbst nicht.
Hab ich auch nicht vor.
Ich guck's mir nur gerne an.
Es ist eher erstaunlich,
wie sehr diese Speedrun-Geschichte
die letzten Jahre gewachsen ist.
Ich guck hier schon ewig
die größeren Events.
Ich hab auch ESA 2013
oder so schon geguckt.
Oder 2012.
Oder 2012 war das erste,
ich weiß nicht,
ich guck das schon sehr an.
Wie groß diese Events mittlerweile sind.
Am Anfang saßen da
drei Dudes in einem Zimmer.
Das war dann irgendwie
im Schlafzimmer
von irgendeinem Typ damals sozusagen.
Und heute hast du quasi eine Halle drinne,
eine Halle mit
300 Leuten oder so.
Das ist echt heftig.
Wie hieß nochmal
das RPG in der Source-Ending,
das du schon mal im Stream gespielt hast?
Das war Dark Messiah of Mind Magic
war das.
Sehr einzigartiges Game.
Gibt's eigentlich
nichts Vergleichbares
in dieser Form.
Ich würde sagen, wenn sie diese Bilder sehen
sieht es ein bisschen aus wie Elder Scrolls,
allerdings wird er feststellen, dass das Combat-System
überhaupt nichts mit Elder Scrolls zu tun hat.
Außer dass es Ego Perspektive ist.
Gibt es auch komplett Tool Assisted Runs? Klar.
Klar. Klar.
Kann man da Bunny hoppen?
Vielleicht. Ich meine, das ist ein Source-Game.
Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn du da irgendwie
ein bisschen anders...
...
So
Wie ist eigentlich
wie ist das eigentlich geworden?
Das hatte ich so auf dem Schirm,
dass es demnächst rauskommt.
ist aber nicht so gut
weil ich dachte mir wenn das mal wieder wenn das ein gutes koop game ist da wäre das was wo ich vielleicht den friseur dazu überreden könnte
die golden eyes speedruns sind auch geil ja das stimmt golden eyes speedruns sind auch nice
also es gibt saumäßig viele saumäßig viele speedruns die geil anzuschauen sind
weil die klassiker schlechthin sind natürlich mario 64 ocarina of time mario 1 und mario world und sowas in der richtung
ich glaube vor allem vor allem mario 64 in ocarina of time dürften so die meist gerundesten schon so die mainstream speedruns eigentlich sein
also auf jeden fall mit die bekanntesten
das hat aber keine gute bewertung das neue wolfenstein
ausgeglichen warum
fuck was give me fucking powers in singleplayer
ja
gta ist auch recht beliebt ja allerdings ich würde sagen ocarina of time und mario 64 sind so die bekanntesten
ja gut es gibt ja kein singleplayer oder ich dachte das game ist komplett koop
koop
insanely repetitive and boring
das habe ich auch schon gesehen dass die jetzt in diesem wolf die haben jetzt hier in jahnblatt haben die so ein level system drinne
dass die dass die gegner obwohl es immer die gleichen gegner sind quasi mit leveln
man darf auch nicht vergessen das ist ein spiel das ist in zusammenarbeit entstanden von den dishonored dudes und noch irgendjemand
und das merkt man das hat mir schon beim ersten mal wo ich das gesehen habe dass es levels gibt nicht gefallen
und anscheinend ist es auch keine
anscheinend ist es auch nicht so gut geworden also ich muss sagen was hat die game star gegeben
warum jahnblatt das schwächste neue wolfenstein ist
fetzigen koop das ist so eine typische game star so eine typische game star rede wendung
ah die hat fetzigen koop
in diablo hat die game star früher geschrieben nicht hack and slay sondern hat die game star geschrieben
blizzards wilde monster hat es
das ist so eine typische game star blizzards wilde monster hat es
da habe ich damals schon immer gegrinscht wo ich das in der game star gelesen habe
obwohl ich damals nicht mehr wusste dass man das cringe nennt
boomer genau
wobei wenn hier einer der boomer ist dann ich mit 35
wo ist denn die bewegung
endlich die bewegung die bewertung
warte mal fazit wertung
wertung
ach haben die mittlerweile gar keine prozent mehr
ach doch da oben 75
die cringe
für den schnellen action hubs am abend das ist auch wieder so eine typische game star so ein typischer game star
für den schnellen action hubs am abend ist jahnblut jahnblut das ist so eine typische game star
für den schnellen action hubs am abend ist jahnblut jahnblut prima
wer seinen wolfenstein lieber gehalt voll marke bleibt bei der hauptserie
der schnelle action hubs am abend
so typisch typisch game star irgendwie
easy
kann man das mittlerweile unzensiert in deutschland spielen kein schlimmer
ich glaube ich glaube new colossus war doch gar nicht in deutschland großartig zensiert
immer außer außer halt nazisymbole
dünne handlung
blödes kurz vor ende
down
das
Okay, was sagt er wie schon ganz zu Beginn muss die story seiten nicht viel. Ja gut
Das hätte ich jetzt auch nicht erwartet wobei ich sagen muss das letzte wolfenstein fand ich die story gar nicht so dumm
Die hatten die hatten also im letzten wolfenstein waren viele wtf momente drin da zum beispiel wo du geköpft wirst und denkst auf fack was jetzt und dann dann
muss dann deinen kopf bergen irgendwie und ich auf so einen so einen
dich wieder festschrauben ich fand die new colossus doch gar nicht schlecht
Aber dass das kurz vor ende derart schwachfugig ausfällt damit hätte ich dann doch nicht gerechnet
Ich will blaskowitz oder den verantwortlichen
Auto immer noch ein bisschen schütteln wenn ich an diesen blödsinn denke, okay na gut wir wissen es ja nicht
Na gut also sie finden die gamestar finden es nicht toll. Ich muss ja sagen ich bin ich hatte früher mal sogar ein gamestar abo
Ich habe schon ewig kein gamestar abo mehr allerdings trotzdem muss ich sagen
Auch wenn auch wenn wenn viel auf die gamestar geschimpft wird und auch wenn ihre ihre seite an sich
Mittlerweile jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt mehr so
Wie soll ich das jetzt sagen so den den gehaltvollste
Gaming journalist muss widerspiegelt ja aber zum größten teil finde ich die gamestar immer noch das beste was wir in deutschland haben
So von den althergebrachten zeitungen
Na manche sachen sind halt easy easy
Easy click crap den sie machen aber das kann man ihnen auch nicht wirklich vorwerfen weil ich meine die müssen geld verdienen die müssen sehen
Die müssen sehen wo sie bleiben
Zum größten teil ist die gamestar immer noch das beste was wir haben
Wo top gillen verzweifeln am schlechtsten boss an der zeit das ist auch wieder so ein so ein so ein so ein so ein
Klick crap so wie ich das mitgekriegt habe wurde jetzt eigentlich gelegt mittlerweile
Wurde eigentlich gelegt jetzt der neue denn der neue
Boss
Ne anscheinend nicht wenn er gelegt worden wäre würde jetzt hier stehen
First world first
Wurde jetzt geklärt mittlerweile
Anscheinlich
Beim aktuellen wo boss ist es ja wohl auch so dass ich deswegen was die gamestar schreibt so ein bisschen
Es ist die spieler regen sich nicht darüber auf dass es zu schwer wäre der boss
Sondern die spieler regen sich darüber auf dass der boss wohl scheiß mechaniken hat zum beispiel gibt es
Wohl, irgendwelche line of sight checks und zwar nicht nur line of sight checks zum spieler charakter
Sondern line of sight checks zu irgendwelchen ads die man tanken muss und die halt
sich nicht so bewegen wie man das gerne hätte
Auf flow 6 9 spick brain ja als chara ist noch unlegbar okay ja wusste ja nicht ob das immer noch so ist aber das letzte mal wo ich geguckt habe am freitag hatte sie
Irgendeine gilde auf 49 prozent und ich weiß nicht wie es jetzt aussieht
Kronk spielt das mit wem spielt das dein co-op
Aber mit dem da anscheinend wer ist das kennt man den
Kennt auf youtube eh kein mehr
Ja habe ich noch nie gehört aber das heißt doch nix weil ich kenne mich auf youtube nicht mal aus was das angeht
Sag mal
Leute ihr seid ja doch bestimmt informierte als ich was war denn eigentlich da letztens los
Ich habe nur irgendwie auf twitter gelesen dass sich alle
drüber aufgeregt haben dass kronk irgendeinen
Irgendein let's play format mit mit mit mit irgendeinem currywurst nicht mehr mit mit wie heißt der her currywurst glaube ich nicht mehr macht
Weil
Irgendwelche sachen waren
Was was da los leute jetzt müsst ihr mir mal erklären was ist da los
Das willst du glaube ich gar nicht wissen doch ich will es jetzt wissen er
Lass mich raten
Irgendeiner ist fremd gegangen mit einem aus der let's play gruppe
Weil meistens sind ja die sachen so ganz
Immer so zwischenmenschlich ja es bestimmt irgendeiner fremd gegangen oder so
Was er hat mit minderjährigen geschrieben und damit seine freundin treiben aber das ist doch sein ding
Also ob der fremd geht ist ja nur wirklich mal sein ding aber gut ich habe die ganze sache nicht mitgekriegt
Ich habe die ganze sache nicht mitgekriegt
Aber gut ich habe die ganze sache nicht mitgekriegt
Aha okay youtube drama ich sehe schon ich sehe schon deutschland youtube drama mal wieder
Und wahrscheinlich
Wollen die ganzen fanboys jetzt natürlich auch alles ganz detailliert wissen und sind sind böse dass ihnen keiner dass das dass man nicht
Jedes detail des privatlebens offenlegen will könnte ich mir vorstellen zumindest ist das immer so auf future wenn er auf twitter das liest
Ja, dann hast du dann immer die die übelsten fanboys am start so nach dem motto
blablabla dem glaube ich kein wort der war schon immer so hinterlistig und
Warum erzählt er uns denn auch nicht was er immer so genau macht und so wo ich mir immer denke als ist irgendjemand verpflichtet seinen fanboys auf twitter
Genau offen zu legen wann er aufs klo geht
Youtube drama youtube drama
Ich folge auch keinem deswegen weiß ich nicht ich habe das nur in den twitter ich habe das nur in den twitter trends
Gesehen
Und da habe ich mir gedacht muss jetzt mal fragen was da eigentlich was da eigentlich los ist ja
Ja
Youtube drama ist immer das beste drama
Youtube drama beste
Wisst ihr früher war es ein drama wenn der eine dem anderen die pentanew weg geklaut hat
Und mittlerweile ist es ja auch nicht besser als in irgendeinem soap im fernseh
Xtroni ist bei mir genauso fernseh gucke ich nicht und mainstream deutschland wohlgemerkt mainstream youtube gucke ich auch nicht
Ich hasse deutschland youtube deutschland youtube ist so ein so ein dreck
Nicht alle muss man kann nicht man kann sich so pauschal auf alle sagen aber zum größten teil ist youtube deutschland totaler dreck
Youtube deutschland will aber auch dass es dreck ist
Viele gab ja ein paar channels die haben auf deutsch videos gemacht wollte keines auch sehen machen sie auf englisch videos finden alle geil
Zum beispiel wenn es ein bisschen in richtung in richtung science und so geht die sind die ganz die diese diese diese wie ist das kurz gesagt
Die haben früher videos auf deutsch gemacht wollte kein menschen sehen machen sie video auf englisch bäm schlägt voll ein
Youtube deutschland ist komplett für ein arsch youtube deutschland ist das schlimmste
So diese die schlimmste nur anzunehmende mischung aus aus casual sensations geilen
Let's play guckenden sensations geilen casual spielern und beauty grills
Das ist youtube deutschland
Fake pranks oder keine fake pranks prank es wofür man dann erstmal in knast muss
Kann es doch jemand an den an den upper upper red bomben prank erinnern
FAKE PRANKS
...
oh man
es ist youtube deutschland
es ist so
es ist so dämlich
habt ihr eure jeezys schon an
alle ja
mit dem prank
der hat doch irgendwann mal
einen
ja was war das
hat er nicht irgendeinen rucksack irgendwo hingestellt
und ist dann weggerannt
so nach dem motto als würde es gleich explodieren
irgendwie sowas hat er doch getrieben in der richtung
und
da war keine bombe drin
aber sie haben das halt glaubhaft
glaubhaft inszeniert
sodass leute gesagt
sie haben davon quasi angst zustände gekriegt
was ich irgendwo nachvollziehen kann
ja
und
ich weiß nicht ob
stimmt das er im knast war
aber ich glaube er war zumindest in untersuchungshaft
oder sowas
also voll für
ein arsch voll beknackt
ja
ja komplett
brain af genau
genau klicks plus 30 IQ
hast du halt das
in kombination
ähm
antrops das stimmt
es gibt im englischen bereich natürlich noch
viel größeren bullshit keine frage
aber ich finde das
gesamtpaket ist in deutschland
einfach zu 90 prozent
kompletter crap und du hast zumindest
im englischsprachigen raum noch
viele sachen die man gucken kann
und auch immer mehr sachen die man gucken kann
die was taugen
natürlich ist der
ober crap
internationaler crap
weil
die deutschen machen das halt irgendwann
auch nach
flow 96
brite zermittiert sich
mikrowelle auf den kopf
youtube
kurz die mal
anschmeißen
ja also wie gesagt sobald die
xenlevels fertig sind
werden wir uns tatsächlich noch
einmal black mesa angucken
es ist jetzt letzten
1. publik beta gestartet
ja
publik beta
wo haben sie denn die news
news
denen hätte ich sonst immer die news auf der seite
ach hier update mini update juli update
some release dates
ok gucken wir mal
am 1. august
gibt es die public beta
von
von dem ersten xenlevel
und dem
diesem graben
die alien grabe die wir eben gesehen haben
half life 1 speedrun
das level mit der alien grabe und das 1. xenlevel
und danach kommen die
anderen drei
ok also wenn das in diesem tempo
weiter geht wie es die letzten jahre weiter ging
können wir uns freuen
wenn es ende des jahres soweit ist
wenn überhaupt
dass die xenlevels rauskommen
und wenn die xenlevels draußen sind
dann
gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns nochmal das komplette
komplette projekt an
kennst du projekt borealis
projekt borealis
nee
macht mir nichts
gönn dir
ok
guck ich schonmal an was ist das
oh das ist irgendein half life mod das können wir uns echt angucken
vielleicht
gibts hier irgendwann mal half life 3
aber eh nicht
ich weiß gar nicht warum ich gaben überhaupt
als overlay hab
hab ich gaben als overlay
oh meine katze macht krach wartet mal
chico was los
ok
die hat nur zeug vom schrank runter geschmissen
also alles halb so wild
Okay, was ist das?
Projekt Borealis, Update 5.
Max, welches Bildbearbeitungsprogramm kannst du empfehlen?
Naja, nachdem ich der absolute Techniknoob bin, äh, der absolute kreative Bildbearbeitungsnoob bin,
hab ich das da.
Das da hab ich.
Ich accepte das alles, ist gut.
So, ähm, das ist für Noobs wie mich optimal, weil selbst damit krieg ich gescheite YouTube Thumbnails hin.
Und das reicht mir.
Oh, das kostet nicht viel.
Oh.
Leute, ich hab den Chat in meiner Vorschau gerade kaputt gemacht.
So, jetzt.
Was hältst du vom Xuantai910 von Alibaba? Weiß ich nicht, muss ich mir mal angucken.
Was ist das überhaupt?
Okay, wir gucken uns aber jetzt erst einmal den Trailer an für diesen Half-Life Mod.
Sound aus, Sound an.
Das ist ja voll, voll pro, wie die das machen, äh.
Okay, es ist noch nicht richtig texturiert, aber das ist ja nicht wild.
Ach, das ist ein Mod, der die Half-Life Story fortsetzt, oder was?
Cool.
Die scheinen auch zu wissen, was die da so treiben.
Was hältst du vom neuen Windows Terminal?
Kann ich gleich was zu sagen, wir haben es ja mal ausprobiert im Stream.
Sind das, sind das diese Saugdinger, die mit dem Tentakel, soll das so ein Monster sein mit dem Tentakel dran?
Weiß ich nicht, wie die Dinger in Half-Life heißen? Die die so hochsaugen und dann reinbeißen?
Die wollen sich ja voll wissen, äh.
Sieht doch schick aus. Aber gut, so Shots kannst du immer machen, die schick aussehen.
Müssen die eigentlich AI selbst programmieren? Source Engine hat doch bestimmt schon ordentlich AI drinne. Oder nicht?
Das sind aber komische Headcrabs.
Der Sound ist cool. Ist das der Original Sound? Hört sich irgendwie wuchtiger an.
Abgesegnet.
Das sieht überhaupt nicht nach Source aus.
Huge Aim.
Ist nicht einfacher gewesen, das in das Source technisch nachzubauen als in den komplett neuen Engine. Zumal ich mir vorstellen könnte, wenn man das auf Unreal 4 laufen lässt, dass dann vielleicht was dagegen hat.
Wenn es ein weiterer Half-Life Mod ist auf Source Basis, auf Steam, dann eher nicht.
Oder ist das irgendwie abgesegnet?
Okay.
Die wollen, dass das Spiel neu aussieht. Ja, neu aussehen tut es. Aber guck mal, die Gun funktioniert auch schon halbwegs.
Das sieht jetzt nicht so schmuckig aus.
Aber da bringt Unreal 4 schon viel mit.
Das ist ja cool.
Weil das im Original Half-Life 2 auch schon ziemlich gut funktioniert hat.
Bisschen übertrieben vielleicht.
Ich meine, das ist schon cool. Die Frage ist halt, also erstens, brauchen wir das in einem Half-Life Spiel? Ich meine, Half-Life 2 war sehr physikalastisch. Und kostet das nicht so viel Zeit, dass man quasi für das eigentliche Game wenig hat. Aber es sieht auf jeden Fall richtig, richtig gut. Das ist übelst nice.
Okay, das ist was, das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen advanceder als das, was damals Half-Life 2 gemacht hat. Ich meine, das ist schon echt nice. Ich meine, das ist richtig cool, oder? Richtig cool.
Das ist sehr gut.
Zeit verwendet und Audio-Technologien verwendet, um Steam-Audio zu nutzen, um
Reverb, Akklusion und Spatialisierung zu handeln, und auch um zu sehen, wie die Klänge
basierend auf ihrer Frequenz zu sein.
Ich meine, es ist wirklich cool, was die vorhaben. Ich weiß halt nicht, ob man das, ob das
jemals fertig wird. Wenn ich mir überlege, wie lange das Black Mesa-Team da dran jetzt
schon rumbaut, die sind ja auch irgendwie über zehn Jahre oder so schon dran, und das
ist immer noch nicht fertig. Wäre ja schon cool, ja.
Ha, Fanatics, ja. Kann ich mir vorstellen. Hab ich ein Auto gemacht.
Sehr gut.
Wir haben nun ein paar Optionen, die wir vornehmen können, um eine letzte Entscheidung zu machen.
Wir haben seit der letzten Update viele andere Aspekte des Spiels gearbeitet,
z.B. die Yeti-Headcrab,
grafische Verbesserungen,
Spieltesten und finalisierende Bewegungen,
neue visualen Effekte,
und die AC-Headcrab.
Außerdem geht es um eine Menge an Alli- und Gegner-Charakten,
einige mehr bekannt als andere.
Wir sind schonmal recht ähnlich.
Und wir hoffen, dass wir später mehr News für euch haben.
Im Moment möchte ich die Entwicklung mehr oft erledigen.
Ich meine, das ist schon echt geil, ja.
Und die meinen das ernst, sonst würden sie nicht einen Aufriss machen, ne?
Und die meinen das ernst, ja.
Wir haben unser erster Developer-Blog dieses Monat erledigt,
um das Spiel-Movement-Code zu beherrschen,
und jetzt müssen wir noch eine Fußgange gehen
As always, we're looking for talented people to join the team in a number of positions.
If you're interested in learning more about a specific role, you can visit our website
at projectborealis.com, where you can read more about each of the available positions.
A direct link to the official Project Borealis Openings page can be found in the video description
below.
If you see a role that interests you and you can lend a few hours a week to the project,
we encourage you to apply.
To stay up to date with the project, you can subscribe to the Project Borealis channel
here on YouTube, follow us on Twitter, subscribe to our subreddit, or come hang out with us
on our public Discord server.
Links to these and more can be found in the video description below.
Until next time.
Also programmieren kann ich da schon mal nicht mit.
Da muss man gut in C++ sein.
Oh grad C++.
Die filmen ja, echt nice, ob es jemals fertig wird ist natürlich fraglich, aber ich find's
ein guter Ansatz.
Was, es schwebt halt über solchen Projekten immer, immer die hier, ne?
Die schweben da immer drüber und wenn die sagen, gibt's nicht, dann ist 5 Jahre Arbeit
für'n Arsch.
Wie rentiert sich sowas gar nicht?
Also Geld verdienen die damit wahrscheinlich nicht, das geht eher so um just for fun und
ähm, tja, Selbstverwirklichung.
Wenn die Black Mesa okay geben, dann auch bei dem, da weiß ich nicht, ich mein Black Mesa
ist immerhin auf Steam, ist Source, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob die da auch okay geben.
Ich mein Valve hat jetzt keine, Valve ist nicht Nintendo, wenn das Nintendo wäre, würde
ich sagen, kannst du komplett vergessen, Nintendo wird sobald da irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise,
was öffentlich gemacht wird, gleich den da ziehen, ähm, Valve hat jetzt nicht so die
Geschichte, Projekte einzustampfen, die sich quasi mit ihren Sachen beschäftigen, bei
Nintendo sieht's anders aus, das ist die Chance, dass die das durchgehen lassen, ist natürlich
gegeben, bei Nintendo nicht, aber ob's fertig wird, müssen wir mal sehen, ich find's auf
jeden Fall eine coole Sache, dann bin ich schon schon on, drei Stunden Leute, ich würd
sagen, wir sind wach, oder, sind wir wach, sonst nehm ich was essen, hast du Subnautica
Speedrun schon mal gesehen, nein, ja nicht, ja Black Mesa spielen wir dann nochmal durch,
wenn, wenn die Zen-Wervels raus sind, Schuantai neun, was ist das, ist ja schnellster RISC-V-Prozessor,
ach das ist die China CPU, hab ich schon mal was von gelesen, ja, das ist die neue China
CPU, ja, kann ich aber nix zu sagen, hab ich schon mal angeguckt, was hältst du vom neuen
Windows-Terminal, ich finde es ist ein guter Ansatz, weil das alte Windows-Terminal, also
das da, ist ja absoluter Crap, das neue ist ganz okay, hat aber immer noch so seine Probleme,
zum Beispiel gehen Emojis nicht richtig, und wir wissen ja alle, dass Emojis im Terminal,
dass Emojis im Terminal das wichtigste überhaupt sind, das heißt, wenn man ein Terminal hat,
wo Emojis nicht funktionieren, geht nicht, Terminal muss Emoji supporten, sonst, sonst
Abmahnung ist raus, Emojis im Terminal, das ist das wichtigste, und ich hätte ja gern
für Gnome-Terminal noch einen Twitch-Emoji-Support, so wie das der Online-Rider gerade schreibt,
ich würde da gerne schreiben können, feelsBatman, und dann kommt feelsBatman, so muss das sein,
okay Leute ich glaube wir sind wach, ich glaube wir sind wach, was macht der hier, Soldaten
der Liebe, es ist verdammt, der abgehört wieder sein PC, ich glaube der hat die gleiche Tastatur
wie ich, Max Schneider, kommen sie schon mal den passenden Vorname, also es sieht ein
bisschen aus wie Javascript, ist Javascript, ne es ist kein Javascript, es ist, oder vielleicht
was ist das für ne Sprache, Rust, ne, was ist das, was ist das für ne Sprache, ich erkenne
die Endung da hinten nicht dran, was ist das wenn du aus Z ist Lupe, ne, Zoom, Lens, das
wird aber halt nichts bringen, weil der Stream so schlecht aufgelöst, ich erkenne es nicht,
was könnte das für ne Sprache sein, was ist das, Swift, Swift, ja, der Captain ZK, das
könnte tatsächlich Swift sein, also wenn man seinen Editor streamt sollte man vielleicht
auch gucken, dass man das erkennt, Videoschnitt, was gibt es denn hier alles, Twitch hängt,
es ist Sony Vegas, irgendwie nix bei oder, 247 Garabis, warum nicht, Chat Overlay SS Service,
hauptsächlich SS Service, wann gibt es Cloud SS Service, ich will meine eigene Cloud,
aber ich will sie nicht selbst bauen, SS Service, Just Chatting auf Deutsch, was haben wir da
so alles, Grills, ja, aiaiai, aiaiai, der edelste aller Runde ist der Hotdog, hauptsächlich
SS Service, so schlecht ey, ok, es sind alle, es sind alle am futtern irgendwie, Zucchini
Brownies, oh, come on brah, oh, ich mein ich saftig, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es funktioniert,
aber klingt nicht gut, so viele Mädels hier, guck dich das mal an, haben wir nen deutschen
Overwatch Streamer, Overwatch, ja, weil haben wir den da auf Deutsch, haben wir da einen
auf Deutsch, den, den ich kenne vielleicht, also man muss echt sagen, der Frauenanteil
auf Twitch ist die letzten zwei Jahre extrem gestiegen und vor allem keine Boobcam Streams
oder ganz normale Streams, das hätt man sich vor ein paar Jahren auch gar nicht vorstellen
können, Streaming Grills, hier kenn ich keinen hier von, Bob Ross, gut Leute, ich weiß nicht,
wen ich hosten sollte, äh, wen ich hosten kann, äh, ich hoste keinen, ich geh jetzt
erstmal was futtern, weil eigentlich war das Stream, wie gesagt, zum aufwachen gedacht
und wir haben jetzt fast 14 Uhr, ich würd sagen, wir sind nach dreieinhalb Stunden sind
wir wach, aber Schluss, bis dann, machts gut, CU.